okay welcome I'm calling the uh public
hearing to order on House Bill 558
welcome everybody and since we are on a
limited schedule this morning I'm going
to get right to calling our oh wait one
second before we do that I forgot I'm
gonna call upon uh representative Brown
to lead us in the National in the uh
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
thank you everybody and I want to again
introduce uh representative Carroll as
the sitting and substitute for uh
representative lewicki while he is
with that said uh representative Ammon
you are the sponsor of the bill please
introduce
morning science technology and energy
committee
for the record my name is Keith Ammon I
represent Hillsboro District 42 the
towns of New Boston Mount Vernon and
lineborough
and in a previous term I served on the
science technology
an energy committee and I really enjoyed
the subject matter that the committee
covers
and so I
House Bill five
eight
uh as you can see by the title it deals
with electric microgrids
and also grid resiliency
so I'm going to give you a little bit of
an overview of what the bill entails
and
just some high level thoughts about what
a microgrid is and the benefits it could
have
so House Bill 558 it allows for
the creation of micro grid zones
so you can think of a microgrid Zone as
a deregulated industrial power zone so
you could imagine an area where there's
a an anchor tenant that could be a large
manufacturer
a consumer of power and the microgrid
allows for
direct relationship with the generator
the power generator
uh and the bill also uh
prescribes some responsibilities if that
microgrid were to connect interconnect
with the main power grid
so
it's a it's an example of an independent
electricity generating area
and so in exchange the microgrid Zone
can assist with a traditional power grid
and balancing its energy systems
through something called demand response
you probably hear a lot about demand
response on this committee
uh the bill aims to attract new
Industries and businesses by offering a
cheaper alternative to traditional
Energy Systems and again improving grid
resiliency and stability
in the bill the department of energy is
responsible for us overseeing all the
microgrids ensuring their ability to
improve grid stability resiliency
and factoring in clean energy production
microgrids are required to provide up to
20 percent of their power generation
to the traditional grid to maintain
stability
the microgrid operator is entitled to
regular rate of return for providing
demand response to the traditional grid
the bill defines microgrid microgrid
zones and domain response and outlines
the processes for partitioning for micro
microgrid designation including a public
hearing and impact analysis
and it also restricts rate regulation
for those consuming electricity within
the microgrid area and prevents recovery
of costs from retail customers outside
the microgrid zone
so uh it affects those that are
operating within the grid but not
and so there's different uh ways that
this can be deployed it could be an
industrial residential commercial
it could be in a university setting and
and uh
just a brief history of
microgrid legislation in New Hampshire
the oldest I could find was back in 2018
and just about every year we've had a
bill
that touched on microgrids in some way
shape or form
and so
there's a there's an interest as
microgrid technology improves and gets
smarter and there's actually a
designation of a smart microgrid where
you have a controller can balance out
the the consumption and generation
within the microgrid and also manage the
interconnection with the rest of the
grid so
um
I uh asked the committee to please uh
you know it's the committee's bill at
this point and uh if there are
improvements I think there's several
people that are going to come behind me
that will have
comments about how to improve this bill
and so I'm I'm interested in you know
making this the best Bill it could be
and uh looking for your input and I'm
happy to take any questions
oh sorry thank you Mr chairman and um
good to see you representative I miss
you being on this committee I apologize
for walking in late and I just want to
make sure that this handout is from you
no that's not for me I believe that's
I see one more question uh
representative Corman
thank you Mr chairman and welcome back I
suppose thank you representative admin
um so I read the bill and I have uh
quite a few questions but I'll just ask
them in turn when I'm recognized uh so I
noticed that the ideas here is that the
microgrid zones are initiated by the
County Commissioners in the county who
petition the department of energy what's
the rationale behind that particular
procedure yeah that's a good question
um so the County Commissioners uh
were
were giving responsibility to the County
Commissioners to know the particular
uh local issues that deal with their
County
so a person that was interested in
creating a microgrid would first go to
the County Commissioners and the County
Commissioners would petition the
department of energy on their behalf
and so it would be some local government
oversight at least at the county level
so that it was a good fit for the local
area that was the thinking with
giving the County Commissioners that
responsibility open to suggestions on
that
I'll take one more question uh
representative muns
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question just as a as a
somewhat of a follow-up to that question
um
I see that there were
um there are limitations on the number
of micro zones in a particular County
and that it can't cross county lines and
then also the size of the um area has to
be a minimum of I believe five acres
yeah what what's the rationale for
putting a limit of three Per County
um it admittedly it's an arbitrary
number
um it's
it's to kind of manage the the growth of
microgrids like obviously if
too many sprung up all at once we might
have issues balancing out
the overall Demand on the grid it was
just to put some brakes on
uh the program not rolling out too
quickly
and Crossing county lines just had to do
with giving responsibility to each
County
again these are all open to suggestions
uh you know we can modify this however
you see fit but it was a starting point
to uh at least provide some minimum uh
size and uh some cap on the number so
that it wasn't uh we didn't have too
many unintended consequences
okay we're going to move on uh we have a
lot of speakers and so I sense uh
they'll be answering some of those
questions behind you representative
thank you so much for your testimony and
um Good Luck
good luck with your recovery
I'm going to call on Mr Dennis Porter at
this point I don't know who he recommend
who he represents he didn't put on his
card
am I on there we go you're on
um well thank you chairman and committee
members
for letting me come here to speak today
and forgive me opportunity I'd like to
introduce myself my name is Dennis
Porter I am the CEO and co-founder of
Satoshi action fund which is a
non-profit non-partisan organization
that focuses on advocating for public
policy at the state level
we also craft public policy to help
States in their path to help improve
their energy systems
I'm here to support this policy and I
hope that I can share some of the
reasons why with you
we believe that this policy will help
the state of New Hampshire
to decrease its energy prices
grow carbon free energy in the state and
other energy projects
that it will drive local investment
and create jobs especially in the North
country
while also improving grid stability and
resiliency throughout the state and
within New England ISO
uh
one of the major factors when you're
considering job growth today is how to
attract new businesses and new
manufacturing to your state
and one of the most important factors
for new industry and
new manufacturing is the price of power
and in New Hampshire and across New
England ISO the price of power is
somewhat unreasonable for most new
manufacturing to take foothold
also traditional Energy Systems today
are not well equipped to help the state
of New Hampshire overcome
this roadblock so we believe that
microgrids can help by providing a
unique solution
are in A New Path for New Hampshire to
be able to overcome this roadblock and
attract New Generation while avoiding
the traditional costs that may be overly
burdensome
in order for a new manufacturer or a new
job Creator to come to the state this is
done by creating microgrids that will be
within these microgrid zones
and the purpose of them is to help new
manufacturing and energy producers to
work in tandem
the product of this policy and the
implementation of it will be more
business and more jobs here in the state
but that's not the only positive
component that microgrids can offer
through this policy
once connected to the traditional energy
infrastructure in the state of New
Hampshire
these microgrids can also balance and
act as an emergency Reserve System
during Peak demand
this will help to keep prices down
during Peak Demand by increasing the
available Supply to ratepayers and the
traditional energy infrastructure
and it will also reduce the need for
costly and often carbon intensive
electrical infrastructure that is used
to support the grid during these Peak
demand moments as you all saw recently
microgrids are not a relatively New
Concept they have been around for
decades but they are growing in
popularity as States and regions look
for new ways to reduce their energy
prices in order to attract new business
a similar policy was introduced and
passed and implemented in the state of
West Virginia
in September
that state was able to attract new
generation and a 500 million dollar
investment
to a rural area of the state
New Hampshire now faces a similar
opportunity only this policy goes a step
further to ensure that all rate payers
and all buyers of power benefit from the
growth of microgrids here in the state
regardless of whether or not they reside
within the micrograder microgrid Zone
itself
this is accomplished by providing the
downward pressure on rates through the
demand response component that is
included within this policy and is the
one major differentiating factor from
the microgrid policy that was passed in
West Virginia and implemented there in
that state
there are various other positive
benefits from US policy and I'm happy to
go over them with you but I would urge
the committee to vote Yes on this bill
and uh thank you for your time and happy
to answer any questions you might have
thank you Ms Powers good presentation
welcome and I'll open up to a couple of
short questions uh representative
Reynolds thank you Mr chairman
um what are the fuels that are
envisioned uh that might be used and you
know the Technologies and the fuels
what's going to fuel these microgrids
it's a great question rep Reynolds thank
you so much for that
um it's an important question to
consider when you're talking about the
growth of microgrids what type of fuels
might be considered or used we you know
we believe that we should be somewhat uh
Tech neutral or Tech agnostic or energy
agnostic in the growth of these systems
and that you know the implementation
should be left up to the Department of
energy and and the states that make the
decisions on what type of fuel source
should be used
the policy does though take a look and
consider you know what type of fuel
source will be used in the
representative Noel please
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question is is there an is there an
interconnection problem for a microgrid
is there some additional equipment that
needs to be brought in to define the
microgrid that's a excellent question
rep no and and thank you for asking it
because we specifically lay out the
interconnection process in the policy
itself
um
microgrids are typically plagued with
two major problems one is that in order
to deal with the excess or lack of
energy on a microgrid they have to
acquire a great interconnection
unfortunately grid interconnections are
extremely expensive and are plagued with
regulatory burden and take a significant
amount of time so oftentimes microgrids
do not get built however with the Advent
of high density flexible loads
microgrids can become somewhat
self-regulatory or self-efficient and
they do not require a grid
interconnection as was typically
important in the past for those systems
to operate functionally
and so now the policy recognizes the
Advent of these new technologies
and lays out a path where those that
want to build the microgrid and new
generation and attract new jobs and
investment can do so once they build the
microgrid or once they start to apply
for it they must apply for grid
interconnection to be connected to the
main grid but they're not required to
have that Grid interconnection at the
moment they start building their
operations however if they're as at some
point a grid interconnection that does
get built uh you know the the
the grid itself the microgrid itself
would have to perform demand response
back to the traditional grid and that's
where the component of grid resiliency
uh representative Harrington for our
last question
uh yeah thank you chairman thank you for
taking my question uh I won't actually
ask a question other than who can I
speak to about the bill because I have
so many questions on this that it would
take me an hour to go through them right
now so who's the right person to talk to
after this so I can answer my questions
I think uh that's a great question yeah
there's a probably several people that
would be good to talk to are you happy
to stay afterwards and discuss with you
and I think also rep representative
Ammon and then you know various other
people like my policy director if you
need really narrowed down details you
know I'm happy to put you in touch with
him as well thank you because there's a
lot of terms in here that I'm not
familiar with they seem to be very
generic and not applicable necessarily
through New Hampshire I'm happy to take
the time to answer any questions you
might have
thank you Cena with further questions
thank you for your testimony Mr Powers
uh thank you for staying around to
answer other questions Offline that
would be great and I think uh
representative Harrington may have a
maybe a good uh straight man because the
next person I'm going to ask to come up
here is uh Mr Griffin Rovers from the
doe and he may have some answers to some
thank you chairman Thomas members of the
committee uh for the record Griffin
rober's State energy program manager at
the New Hampshire Department of energy
the department is neutral on the bill
um as the bill analysis Notes
establishes The Authority for and
procedures for uh adoption of electric
microgrids
given some of the questions that the
committee has asked here today I think
the department would respectfully be in
the same camp we would very much welcome
the opportunity to talk to the Bill's
sponsors and any supporters about the
intent of this language as there are
some very large and basic questions that
have not been fully resolved and talking
with uh folks in our regulatory Support
Division there was some observations
that maybe this bill might fit well in
other states but is not necessarily
suited to the way New Hampshire's
electric utility utilities are
structured
um
some of the observations that we know is
that uh some several of the definitions
on page one
um seem rather loose and might welcome
some further specificity
um I know an earlier question was asked
about the rationale for microgrid zones
being minimized to an area set at five
acres we are not aware of the rationale
for that I think we'd welcome the
opportunity to understand that
who controls the microgrid who oversees
the Opera the microgrids operation how
does it work with the local electric
distribution utility whether that be
unitel Liberty or eversource I know that
there's a definition of microgrid
operator in there but um I think we view
the definition of microgrid operator is
quite broad
there is a role for the county to play
um in petitioning the department to get
a microgrid Zone
um approved but does the county have any
role following that that process does it
fall to the municipal penalties do they
have any role in it those are areas that
I think would be welcomed as well most
significantly I think the department
would certainly require additional
resources in order to implement the
provisions of this statute
um
per page two you'll see that our bottom
of page one and top of page two the
department of energy
um
is the body where where counties will
petition to approve these microgrid
zones
um lines three to five on page two
indicate that the department of energy
energy shall complete an analysis of the
potential impact the microgrid Zone
might have on retail customers we view
potential impact as quite broad
what exactly is the department vetting
with these microgrid proposals again
further specificity over there would be
welcomed
we do not anticipate that reviewing
these petitions will be easy we realize
that there will be a level of complexity
so I think we anticipate that additional
Staffing Resources would be needed
um
additionally
um some in our department highlights
some cyber security concerns the bill
makes no reference to any type of cyber
security provisions such as who protects
the microgrid how is it protected those
types of things those are just some of
the questions that we have internally in
the department and again we'd welcome
the opportunity to speak with the Bill's
sponsors about it and uh with that I'm
more than willing to answer any
questions the committee might have thank
you Mr Roberts uh I'll call on
representative Munds please
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
coming back again on this beautiful
Monday yes yes
um
I I had a lot of questions as well and
and one of the questions I had and I
don't know if you
um uh have the same question or were you
able to to to figure out or have an
answer to my question the prices that
the microgrid would charge its customers
are those gonna are those regulated
thank you for the question
um under as uh as far as I understand
there aren't any approved micro grids in
the state of New Hampshire that
utilities work with on a regular basis
as they go on and off the grid so I
think it'd be premature to maybe ask
that question I I don't necessarily have
an answer for that just because we don't
really have a lot of case examples here
okay thank you Mr oberge for your
testimony uh you're accused thank you
and I'm going to call on Mr Michael
good morning uh Michael Licata
representing eversource energy uh I'll
try not to be duplicative I think we
have a number of the same concerns as
the department of energy laid out
appreciate the opportunity to to testify
appreciate the sponsors uh filing this
legislation we are opposed as written
but we are certainly supportive of the
development of microgrids
microgrids can can actually be quite
useful to both the end user as well as
the utility they can be used to increase
reliability uh they can be used to
reduce cost versus more traditional
wired alternatives to improve resiliency
in a specific area
eversource by way of background we
actually have a bit of
experience in the development of
microgrids in Massachusetts we actually
got a approval and brought online a
microgrid system a battery storage
system in place of a transmission
upgrade for Province Town at the edge at
the edge of the cape that was a 25 just
under 25 megawatt battery storage system
that again functions to improve local
reliability in New Hampshire folks might
recall that we actually proposed a 1.7
megawatt battery in Westmoreland that we
did not get approval for but it would
have been a similar type of concept
um we are concerned with the broad scope
of the bill it's not clear to us exactly
how this would interact with existing
state statutes specifically around Net
metering and group net metering which
allows for multiple entities to
participate in a single generation
installation
we would also note as Mr Roberts noted
it would be a significant expansion of
the Doe's current role really in the put
them in the role of of almost a grid
operator in terms of reviewing the
engineering and design and interaction
between these micro grids and the
utilities and it's really unclear how
the utility based upon this the language
would would be interacting with the doe
when these grids were were proposed the
review that would be required of the
Department of energy presumably would be
based on
utility engineering and design so how we
would would inform them interact with
them about uh our system where the the
microgrid was proposed
that said as I started we do have
experience in microgrid development we
do think that there's there's value in
some of the concepts in the bill we
would be happy to work with the bill
sponsor and other stakeholders there's a
lot here and you know would politely
suggest perhaps retaining this
legislation to get worked on in a more
comprehensive fashion might be a good
outcome and with that be happy to answer
any questions that the committee may
have
representative uh public Corman please
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
again Mr locata I'm referring
specifically to page 3 Lines 19 through
21.
which says if utilities are unwilling or
incapable of funding the grid
interconnection microgrid operators May
fund the connection at which point the
microgrid operator will be exempt from
any cost to maintain their connection uh
I'm wondering if you interpret this the
same way as I do which is that the
utilities might say no we don't really
want to fund this interconnection The
microgrid Operators connect and then the
utility is on the hook to maintain it is
is that how you interpret it
um
potentially I I think that's it's sort
of a good example of where the bill
could use a bit more clarity so the way
it works right now is if someone is
installing generation storage the
utility does an engineering evaluation
of that interconnection and
interconnection study
if there are costs associated with uh
upgrading the local distribution system
at that location based upon that
engineering study the developer who who
is proposing it is required to pay for
that so that the cost is not sort of
socialized to to all customers so that's
how it works today
this contemplates that the utilities
would be unwilling or incapable of
funding the grid interconnection which
again is not how it works currently and
then after that it's it's a little
we're a little unclear but certainly
what you're suggesting could be a
potential outcome of that language
sorry if that's not particularly
Direct
thank you and thank you for your
testimony seeing no others questions I
will now call on a Mr Joseph kowasnik
please
272. oh my apologies I got mixed into
this okay
in that case I'll call on Mr uh Sam
Evans Brown from clean energy New
Hampshire
thank you members of the committee uh
for the record I'm Sam Evans Brown I'm
the executive director of clean energy
New Hampshire
um we uh are neutral on the bill and as
as written I think uh folks have
spotlighted already some of the some of
the questions that I had when when this
came across my my desk but similarly to
eversource I just want to uh say that we
are very supportive of the concept of
developing microgrids be very happy to
work on this bill to try to try to make
it better
um we you've heard a bit already about
the the prospect of using these type of
Investments uh as as so-called non-wires
Alternatives if you're not familiar with
that term the idea is that utilities as
a as as it stands uh as load grows in a
given area the the standard response is
to build out new uh transmission and
distribution infrastructure that are
poles and wires that you know poles
wires and Transformers the types of
things that we're all very familiar with
but as the technological landscape
changes there's the opportunity to use
some of these newer technologies that
are in fact invested in by customers and
are customer cited to avoid those those
Investments and lower the cost of the
grid overall and I think that really is
uh ought to be the The Guiding star when
considering how to establish a microgrid
program and I think that that this bill
maybe doesn't quite get there but but
it's there's there's some really great
ideas in here that we can that we can
work with with the sponsor to try to try
thank you for your short testimony uh
and uh
I'm going to call him representative
Brown for a question
could you clarify that for me a little
bit more about the non-wired piece
somewhere there has to be wires right
sure yeah so so my my favorite story
about this is on from the Boothbay
peninsula in Maine uh which which uh if
anyone's been to Boothbay is a lovely
little town that's that's chock full of
art galleries and tourism attractions
um and was experiencing substantial load
growth and so uh CMP the you know
Central Maine Power the utility there
wanted to extend a new power line down
to Boothbay that was going to cost
somewhere in the neighborhood of 18
million dollars
um a a small startup uh proposed an
alternative proposal that said Hey what
if we could do the same thing which is
deliver the the the you know the what
the service is the electricity provides
but for Less cost and their proposal
included
um citing storage down at the end of the
peninsula battery storage it included
investing aggressively in efficiency so
they installed LED lighting and all the
little coin art gallery freeze down on
the on the tip of the peninsula
installed uh um they also installed
thermal storage so that we were refer to
as ice bear air conditioners that make
ice at night and then just blow a fan
over the ice during the day so it's it's
a way to do thermal storage as opposed
to using air conditioning and then you
know evaluated the costs of all those
interventions when the pilot was done
this is a pilot program the cost was
somewhere in the order on the order of
1.8 million dollars and avoided an 18
million dollar transmission line upgrade
so that's the non-wild wires alternative
can can look like a lot of things
anything that reduces demand can avoid
the need to invest in in new
infrastructure but it can also look like
traditional small scale generation cited
with you know industrial industrial
purposes as was as the the sponsor
described
um representative Reynolds question
thank you Mr chairman Sam thanks for
bringing up describing that that real
world example uh is there a report
online somewhere a case study that was
written about that so so folks could
read yeah the main Public Utilities
Commission did uh has studied that
because because it was a pilot
initiative there's been extensive sort
of reporting and study of it and I'd be
oop thank you Mr chair thank you for
coming in
um what's the difference between a
how'd that happen uh quite a lot uh so
so group net metering is uh what results
when you have a a uh behind the meter
generation asset that is partially
offsetting the load of a customer but
then also allowed to export its power
out onto the grid and uh and is then
resold by you know essentially resold by
the utility it's a little more
complicated than that but but that's
that the general Arrangement
um a a microgrid's quite a bit more
complex it typically has the ability to
Island which is to say if the power goes
out the the microgrid continues to
function whereas your standard net
metering host does not
um and and similarly uh you know
microgrids can use all sorts of
different types of generation where
whereas uh group net metering typically
is is uh you know Hydro solar or small
scale wind
um in uh in Connecticut where the the
most aggressive microgrid program in New
England is is located there's actually a
fair amount of fuel cells that are being
used for for microgrids
um so just to say they're they're they
really are two very separate types of
so you know the questions thank you uh
Mr Sam Evans Brown for coming here you
are a frequent contributor to our
committee
okay I'm going to call on the last
speaker of Mr Drew Armstrong and uh in
the interest of fairness to our other
speakers if you could keep your
presentation down to just a few minutes
I understand
that's okay just the sailing points do
you have any written testimony
discussed
uh hey sorry
um I'm uh Drew Armstrong the president
and CEO of Cathedral Bitcoin uh a
Bitcoin mining company that has had
operations here in Northern New
Hampshire manufacturing operations for
the last
um 12 months and
Isaac fidion hello I'm the chief field
of operations manufacturing officer for
Cathedral Bitcoin sort of recruited
Cathedral Bitcoin to come into Northern
New Hampshire to do manufacturing there
so we've been building our mobile
modular data centers we call them Rovers
up in Northern New Hampshire and working
with lots of other local business up
there to to do that we have a contractor
model so we use local electricians uh
local Steel Workers what have you so
Tom I'm a New Hampshire native born and
raised and I'm excited about the
potential to bring jobs to New Hampshire
yeah and so representative those we will
keep it quite brief uh but I just wanted
to offer a uh called business
perspective for what microgrids and what
this legislation could mean
um at Cathedral Bitcoin we believe
that's sound money and abundant energy
are the keys to human flourishing and in
fact we believe all wealth creation
requires energy as an input and there's
no uh it's an inevitable aspect of
wealth creation Now I think the main
benefits that microgrids can offer
especially a state like New Hampshire is
the ability to improve energy improve
the energy system over time through
allowing pockets of experimentation
whether that's new forms of generations
say like small modular reactors or uh
potentially unlocking the role that
Bitcoin mining can play as a um you know
dispatchable load that can help improve
grid resiliency uh help support base
load generation uh and potentially
provide new ways to uh create jobs uh
and Industry up in um
States like New Hampshire particularly
yeah and uh you know one of the things
that we've been working on quite extent
oh sorry about that one of the things
we've been working on quite extensively
is the ability to load shed so I come
from a company prior to this called
Great American Mining and we developed
some prototype modular data centers and
the primary purpose of those was to take
advantage of wasted flare gas and oil
and gas industry so
you go out and you have this multi-story
flame burning 24 7 it's not being used
for anything uh anything productive it's
just pollution and waste and so we would
go out to those sites capture the gas
clean it up and use that as a fuel input
to power these mobile data centers and
one of the limitations of that is you
need to be able to shed load quickly if
there's a gas loss and this kind of take
on generation where you can respond to
the availability of power is something
that we believe could be quite useful to
ISO New England in general where you
could have these uh what we have
designed these modular data centers they
could shed load quite rapidly within a
second so if you're in a peak demand
period instead of turning on a bunch of
oil
powered generation you could just shed
load quite quickly and that could
provide stability to the grid and to
lower costs and reduce carbon emissions
as well
and so just to conclude we think that
legislation like this that supports and
promotes micro grids and experimentation
within the energy system and responsible
siled Pockets has the ability to have a
hugely positive impact on the grid as a
whole
excellent thank you so much for
respecting the time and being able to
concisely State everything it was very
nice representative Harrington has a
question I'll make it short thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question would you anticipate companies
like yours if this was to be passed
would take on a capacity a formal
capacity Supply obligation with ISO New
England and the forward capacity Market
uh well so I I think with this
legislation is uh at least from my
opinion most interesting is it allows
for uh novel ways to
um Design Energy Systems for example say
you have a series of small modular
reactors with capacity uh with a
generation capacity in excess of what uh
the average local demand is
microgrids would allow for
experimentation where you could have
Bitcoin mining buttress that generation
and be a willing um call it uh demand
response partner to switch off whenever
the local Demand on that micro grid uh
you know reaches near near Peak now in
terms of uh entering into a deal with
ISO New England for say a long-term PPA
um you know excuse me it wouldn't be a
PPA it's a capacity Supply capacity
Supply yeah Bitcoin miners could could
absolutely enter into the capacity
markets um I'm not sure if the exact uh
I would need to talk to the gentleman
from eversource and some of the other uh
folks in ISO any but Bitcoin mining
theoretically could be a participant in
the capacity markets yeah
representative Reynolds
thank you Mr chairman um
I'm generally supportive of the idea of
microgrids technological progress it
sounds wonderful that
your microgrid might be able to jump in
and supplement the Grid at periods of
peak times
but again I asked the question what do
you envision your microgrid being fueled
by do you intend to build especially
here in the North country
what's going to fuel it uh are you going
to build renewable generation
or what
um for the sake of uh uh leveling uh
expectations I don't think our company
is well capitalized enough to uh build
an entire micro good ourselves and to
find its entire microgrid ourselves that
said uh I I think the the generation
source that uh I think is most appealing
long term uh especially in the context
of microgrid uh are small modular
Advanced nuclear reactors
um that effectively some of them have
the ability to use nuclear waste as fuel
and help address that problem as well
um but you know smrs and nuclear actors
in general typically are slow to ramp up
and down generation something like a
microgrid here could be perfect where
they're able to build the reactors on
there on their sort of schedule are not
necessarily beholden to utility
transmission build out uh and if they
have captive demands in the area on that
microgrid then they they have the
ability to serve whatever communities
and businesses are there with Bitcoin
mining being a tool to help help make
sure that was economically viable and
then of course if there is ever demand
from the grid and there is an
interconnection built
um obviously you know the more the the
larger the energy system is and the more
different pockets of generation it can
draw from the better it is for
resiliency and hopefully for Consumer
okay same well no further questions
thank you so much a very interesting as
a matter of fact thanks for coming up
here don't be a stranger come back again
thank you
with that I have no other
pink slips for speakers so I will close
House Bill 558 and ask representative
Pelosi to give the reading on the blue
sheets and online
I will thank you chair uh may I get that
information to you later I do not have
it at the moment okay
um before I open up the next
public hearing I would just like to make
a rather sad announcement but a former
representative Gary Hopper passed away
last night after his struggle with
cancer we just got noticed this morning
or yes this morning my sympathy to his
family and friends
so
with that said I will open up
let's see here
370 372 and ask the prime sponsor
representative Kaplan to come up and
foreign
good morning Mr chair and good morning
colleagues of the science technology and
energy committee
for the record my name is Tony Kaplan
and I represent mayor Mack 8 the towns
of Henniker Bradford and Warner
and I'm here today to present house bill
372.
which is intended to establish a study
commission to look at the short and
long-term impacts of carbon pricing
mechanisms on the regional and National
level
on the people industry businesses and
environment of the State of New
Hampshire
so I will be brief in my testimony
because I believe that there will be
people up here subsequently who will be
much better place to uh
to give a you know a granular and
nuanced uh perspective on this issue but
um and brief what is carbon pricing
carbon pricing is a is a tool enacted at
a economy wide scale that's uh intended
to levelize the the playing field among
energy generating sources so that the
the hidden subsidy that no one pays at
the moment on the market for the
production and consumption of fossil
fuels is brought onto the balance sheet
so to speak so that people can make true
cost
uh calculations and so that the least
cost most efficient way of doing
business will be the way that wins the
day so to speak
uh so what what are what are the what
are the impacts what are the hidden
subsidies that uh at present nobody
really pays uh the impacts of the
production and consumption of fossil
fuels would include things like the
human health impacts which at the
present and the United States has
calculated at 60 billion dollars a year
including 230 000 deaths
um due to the production and consumption
of fossil fuels impacts would include
things like climate change impacts like
the destruction of crops severe weather
events which I think in uh 2022 alone in
the United States there were 18 such
severe weather events when the average
previous you know in previous decades
has been three or four these 18 severe
weather events cost over a billion
dollars each and so what is the the
fraction attributable to the production
and consumption of fossil fuels in New
Hampshire that's a calculation that you
know that economists make an
increasingly accepted by businesses and
in governments
so what other impacts are we talking
about climate change refugees refugees
people from countries not as resilient
as ours where a drought or a flood means
they have one choice and that is to pack
up and go because their livelihoods are
no longer viable and their lives are at
risk
so all these impacts put together uh go
into what people call the Social cost of
carbon these are calculations as I said
they're increasingly accepted by
governments and businesses the EPA has a
has a tool the social cost of carbon
where they calculate that it's I think
roughly 190 dollars per ton of carbon
and that would take into account all the
impacts
of the So currently a hidden subsidy for
the production and consumption of fossil
fuels so um
the fact that these are calculations
that are already being made and widely
accepted makes it easier to implement
economy-wide tools such as the carbon
pricing regime and we see that these are
spreading uh around the world uh the
European Union has a carbon pricing
regime it's the second or third largest
economy in the world and they just
recently announced in the last couple
months that they will begin enacting
what they call border adjustment fees
which is a fee on products coming across
their borders from places such as our
country that don't have carbon pricing
regimes which means that our products
are at a disadvantage China is
discussing this there are six provinces
in Canada that are currently uh
you know administering a carbon pricing
regimes inside their borders and there's
discussion at the federal level in
Canada certainly discussion in
Washington especially with the Biden
administration's zero carbon Gold by
2050.
there's a push to get to zero carbons
carbon neutral economy by 2050 and So
currently we see a raft of subsidies a
raft of mandates coming down including
the inflation reduction act which we're
all familiar with and these are all
intended to move us to carbon neutral
economy by 2050 but the experts are
saying that this is not going to be
enough it's going to be close but not
quite enough and so that a tool such as
a carbon pricing regime which is a very
simple elegant market-based tool it's
one number it takes to the place of all
those mandates all those subsidies will
be the will be the really the the ticket
to getting us to that last mile so to
speak of getting to carbon neutral by
2050. so this bill is not intended to to
argue for a carbon pricing regime in the
state of New Hampshire it's saying that
these are these are mechanisms that are
spreading around the world there's a
discussion in Washington there's a
likelihood that this will happen and
that as a state as leaders of the state
we should be taking a look and looking
around and seeing what the impacts are
on our businesses on our interests on
our people and preparing for the days
should it come that that we're facing a
regime like that at the federal level or
even a regional level we can see that to
the South the state of Massachusetts is
talking about it so there are individual
states as well that are looking at this
so um that's my bill in a nutshell I
will say that at the suggestion of my
colleague representative Muntz I would
like to offer an amendment uh to be
before you by next Thursday executive
session not next or this Thursday and
that would be to add two positions to
spots on the commission to the
Department of energy currently there are
no spots on for the Department of energy
so that's an oversight that I think
needs to be corrected also to lengthen
the study period so that the current
date of November 2023 would be an
interim report and they would have an
additional year to come up with a final
report so those are two amendments that
I think will be before you on Thursday
and if there's any other ideas that come
out of the discussion today I'd be happy
to work with those
um I will add one more thing I've got a
scoot after this but I shall return in
the afternoon as Douglas MacArthur said
well he didn't say the afternoon but he
said he'd be back and I I will be back
as well
um so with that I'd conclude my
testimony and happy to try to take any
questions
thank you representative Kaplan um
question from representative notter
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
your testimony every term we have a
carbon bill and I I saved it I have a
file I just keep adding to it my
question for you is after
all is implemented and taxed how much
does the carbon pricing actually lower
well I don't have an exact answer for
you for the exact precise number but
what I do know is that the the experts
what they say is that the carbon pricing
mechanism is the most effective way of
getting lowered carbon emissions because
it actually leads people to make
rational decisions in the marketplace
based on the true cost of the fuel
and so as opposed to like mandates
coming from top down from the government
saying You must do this or you're going
to get in trouble or some kind of
subsidy some kind of carrot as they call
it you know to try to entice you to do
things there's nothing more effective
than actually having a market-based
mechanism that will lead you to make
rational cost-based decisions
follow-up
follow-up well I have several sources
that say that it it will be lowered by
.002 percent and I have to go put on my
other hat but I too shall return this
afternoon thank you for your question
representative
okay see no further questions thank you
so much for your testimony and I will be
looking forward to seeing you coming
back this afternoon
uh I will call upon Mr Joe fantaine from
the Fontaine from the Department of
good morning thank you for the
opportunity to speak again for the
record my name is Joe Fontaine I
represent uh Des
excuse me
uh Des has no position on the bill but I
just wanted to provide some information
that might be useful to the committee
there are a couple of uh reports out
there on carbon pricing that may be of
interest
one is by the carbon pricing leadership
Coalition and that was issued in 2022
I have one copy of each report but I did
email links to the two reports to the
committee earlier this morning
the second report is the state and
trends of carbon pricing also issued in
2022 by the World Bank
um
so those provide background on carbon
pricing
of course at the at the regional level
we already have Reggie which is a form
of carbon pricing
it's limited to the electricity sector
it's not economy wide
um
that's briefly all I intended to um to
speak on today I just wanted to make the
committee aware of those two reports
thank you Mr chairman
um just harkening back to representative
nodders question to the bill sponsor
we've had Reggie which is as you said
carbon cap
ricing carbon emissions allowances for
over a decade and there's lots of
reports out
they're not about the effect of
Reggie in reducing the carbon intensity
of
generation electric generation in the
region yes any comment on that
well Des issues an annual report to to
this committee
and the annual report includes a graph
that shows the emission reductions that
have occurred since the beginning of
Reggie and they are significant over 50
percent I believe
so over 50 percent it's way more than
point zero zero
zero two percent for example for New
Hampshire specifically uh Baseline
emissions which I think are uh 2005 if
memory serves
um or from the applicable Reggie sources
were eight
a little over eight million and
um most recently they're a little under
three million I believe so thank you
I
uh question representative Harrington
yeah just to follow up to this uh
figures you put out is it correct to say
that the overwhelming majority of that
savings was a result of transferring
from generating electricity using oil
and coal to Natural Gas
I'll take Liberty of one last question
are you you did mention two reports are
there carbon carbon processing is Is Not
A New Concept are there other reports
out there or examples that the state can
glean from
this subject matter uh as opposed to
having another commission to study the
um
I think this has been mostly talked
about at the federal level and um as was
mentioned by the bill sponsor
uh with the inflation reduction act that
was enacted
um that's sort of an alternative to
carbon pricing so that's
um
you know funds grant money to fund
projects
and
um I think that both of the
organizations that I have uh
brought up today
previously in years past also issued
reports so they're they issue periodic
reports
um
off the top of my head I'm not aware of
others but there probably are
um
that have information on carbon pricing
okay thank you so much and thank you for
your testimony thank you uh next I'll
take the liberty of calling on The
Honorable Marge shepardson who had been
a long-term member of the Science and
Tech committee welcome back Marge it's
a little bit
others have
given you statistics and and people
after me can give you more details I'd
like to just stick with the big picture
for what we're dealing with here we know
that climate change is happening
primarily through the use of burning
fossil fuels and when the tub is
overflowing I'm sure you've heard this
analogy the first thing you do is turn
off the tap well carbon fee and dividend
would help us turn off the tap of more
carbon emissions and then we could deal
with what's left behind and start
cleaning up the mess I think business as
usual is costing us a lot in terms of
health in terms of infrastructure
replacement after big storms etc etc and
business as usual is not really an
option
carbon fee and dividend is a way as a
way to
give us some time so that we can as I
said deal with the mess
I don't think we should be waiting for
one magic solution I know their ideas we
can blow Moon dust in the air and
reflect the sunlight all kinds of things
but we have a tool right here with
carbon fee and dividend that has been
proven to be effective it is not a big
government intervention it's a marketing
market-based intervention and it's um
the money for it would come from
putting a price on pollution and causing
uh people who cause the problem to help
us
collect money so we can deal with it in
the past I know six years ago I heard
some of the same arguments and you're
probably tired of hearing the same
things every year but
um
just saying that such a policy carbon
fee and dividend would harm low-income
people or that it would hurt the economy
or that it's going to grow government
these things can be said that doesn't
make them true I also remember hearing
big tobacco say smoking is not harmful
to your health well you can say it that
doesn't make it so let's rely instead on
years and decades even of scientific
data of reports that tell us what is
really happening and give us realistic
projections of the way we're going
you're our leaders and I hope in this
case you will lead and allow us to study
the effects of carbon pricing on New
Hampshire tourism businesses
our economy our residents
and uh I really hope you'll take this
under consideration and vote yes thank
you
thank you thank you of The Honorable
shiverson I'm sorry I almost called you
representative but it says as you were
next I'm going to call okay just an
announcement we have six more speakers
and we're already out of our a lot of
time so but they all I'm sure are going
to say the same thing so I'm going to
invite Mr Joseph kowasnik up for his um
thank you Mr chairman my name is Joe
quasnick I'm representing myself
my background is is many years of
working for the National Grid as a vice
president of environment and head of
climate change I've also served as a
director and chairman of the New
Hampshire Electric Co-op and have worked
as a senior advisor energy advisor to a
series in Boston my testimony will be
very short one is I think this bill
focusing just on the bill itself tells
us that it will produce a commission
that will in in the reading of the bill
is will be bipartisan and I do believe
that that bipartisan commission will be
able to come up with answers about what
the impacts of of carbon pricing will be
on New Hampshire in the future it's
important to to learn these things
because
we will be sometime in the future will
be surrounded by a sea of states around
us and certainly and nationally that
will produce that will be requiring
carbon pricing on its own generators and
inventors of carbon within their states
and um you have to understand I think
you all you all do understand is that
much of our electricity because we are
tied into the regional grid much of our
electricity comes from out of state
typically Massachusetts New York Maine
and other states and those states are
already moving down the path of putting
carbon pricing in place and you you have
to understand that the price per
megawatt hour of electricity imported
into our state from those States will
have a carbon price built into that
megawatt hour so we need uh to get back
to the bill we need to understand that
process we need to understand uh how
these mechanisms will work
and um and and do that in such a fashion
that we could then craft our own
strategies within New Hampshire how to
deal with that I'm not questioning or or
challenging uh climate change I think
it's a it's a reality but I'm thinking
more about the economic impacts of what
will happen to New Hampshire if we don't
begin to recognize what's happening with
outside of our state lines but also
within our state lines and I have um
just a little perspective I was one on a
stakeholders group for the Reggie
process back in the uh back when
dinosaurs still roamed the Earth but um
we found that with Reggie if you did not
participate in the Reggie process all
the states that were crafting the Reggie
policies and regulations if you weren't
at the table you were put in a distinct
disadvantage as a state for the same
reasons I just mentioned that
electricity would be importing into New
Hampshire and you would still have the
Reggie premiums built into that into
those those uh megawatt hour costs for
electricity and um and if you didn't
join Reggie you still paid those costs
and then and could not benefit from the
auction proceeds so it's a similar
analogy and I think that unless we
understand those processes New Hampshire
will be put a great distinct uh
disadvantage both economically and also
from an environmental point of view
so I appreciate the time thank you very
much and if there's any questions I'm
say no questions thank you so much for
your testimony appreciate it appreciate
it thank you we'll be hanging around
later or are you set to go what do you
mean by hanging
staying I will stay yes that's okay
okay I will call next on a
barbarous
South herd
yes
sorry and what was that pronunciation
again
South hurt Southward thank you Southern
thank you for allowing me to come today
and listen and
um I'm coming because I believe that
carbon pricing is absolutely positively
in our future whether we like it or not
and if we don't prepare for it we're
going to suffer the consequences
Canada the UK and many other countries
already have it and because they do
products with a high carbon content and
that's like iron steel cement fertilizer
aluminum and of course fossil fuels they
cost more in these countries
and it makes them less competitive and
that means that the industries in those
countries consider relocating well
that's not that's not what they want but
enter carbon border adjustment mechanism
are also called sebam
with cbam countries that don't have a
hard carbon price they have to pay a fee
or sometimes called a levy if they want
to export products that have a high
carbon content across the border there
and uh you have a model of that on your
sheet there and
um
and if they do that
you know is the US going to want to
follow
suit I'm sure other countries will
especially Canada the EU is already
transitioning to this c-bam
um in October of this year
so
it's coming
and the U.S is going to want to do it
too because Industries are going to be
pushing Congress to do it
because
it's in their best interest they want to
be competitive
the problem is is you can't establish a
sea band without already having
a carbon price domestically
so that's why this is coming because
industry is going to push for it just
like they did the Kigali Amendment
so carbon fee and dividend as you've
heard before that's already been
proposed in Congress
and you've got a model of that too where
we're going to put a gradually
increasing price on carbon high carbon
content products at the source and all
of that Revenue goes back to the
citizens in equal portions
it is it popular well
um most people are just not familiar
with it they don't even know what you're
talking about but when they find out
they are supportive in fact in New
Hampshire here 38 towns have already
passed a resolution endorsing this
policy and more towns are scheduled to
vote on it this year
so um what would happen here in New
Hampshire if we had carbon cash back or
cbam
I think I think it's important to study
this what we want to put in more solar
and wind
would we want to build some charging
stations maybe as people move to EVs and
that's good for tourism if they have a
place to charge isn't it
and would we see more Innovation and job
creation
I believe carbon pricing and c-bam are
definitely in our future
but these policies do take time to enact
I think we need to use that time wisely
please vote to establish this Commission
New Hampshire needs to prepare for a
sustainable prosperous and healthy
future
thank you very much
thank you well done thank you
a question from representative Summers
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question I notice on the sheet
here you have the the carbon fee and
dividend carbon cash back with a hundred
percent of the net revenue going back to
the rate payers
we do that with Reggie right now as far
as goes back to ratepayers however right
now there's a bill that's actually we
just heard about yet last week that
takes that money away from the rate
payers and puts it towards more uh
incentives for the uh for solar and wind
and such do you believe that the rate
payers would be in favor of this if they
knew they weren't going to get anything
back and it was going to Renewables
instead
probably not
no I think it's important to give it
back
Representatives do you have a question I
do are we discussing this carbon uh
pricing Bill are we discussing the uh
other bills yes
100 carbon cut out of this bill right
that you did you get that cut out
yeah
I think in this particular case the
question on does it work the same as was
was relevant and it wasn't carried any
further so I think it was
good
thank you chair
um there's one particular aspect of this
bill that I have trouble getting a
handle on and that is whether or not the
state or the federal government would be
the best Avenue for enacting this type
of legislation I think a study report
would probably answer that but I don't
know could you give me your thoughts on
that
I'm not sure if I understand the
question but I think maybe it's about
whether carbon cashback would be state
or federal
should Outlaws it could be either but if
the federal government creates a carbon
cash back policy that would supersede
the state for sure
is it good uh in part but I'm also
wondering where the most appropriate
place for this type of legislation is
whether it be more appropriate to deal
with carbon cash back on a state level
or a uniform Federal level and I really
don't know I must I'm looking for I mean
right now I understand there is federal
legislation going forward with carbon
cash back well I think the most
appropriate level is federal myself but
you one way to prepare for the federal
one is to go state
I think it would be because what what
what the carbon cashback does is it just
changes the market forces altogether
and it drives Innovation job creation
and of course energy of efficiency
renewable energy you know all of those
things it drives that and what would
happen then is we'd be prepared for that
federal policy
thank you
okay well thank you so much for your
testimony well done
I'm going to call next on a Joan Whitmer
thank you for giving me a moment to
provide some testimony in support of
this piece of legislation my name is
Joan Whitmer and I'm a 43-year resident
of the town of Amherst New Hampshire I'm
also a registered nurse who works for a
home health care agency and we routinely
see patients in our service that suffer
from chronic respiratory diseases such
as COPD congestive obstructive pulmonary
disease and congestive heart failure
these patients experience exacerbations
of their conditions when we have high
heat index days and as you know the
number of high heat index days is
growing in the state of New Hampshire
and that this results in unplanned
unscheduled exact emergency department
visits which have of an increasing cost
in health care to the residents of this
state both through premiums such as
Medicaid and through insurance premiums
that we as individuals pay when insured
individuals have higher utilization of
emergency departments it's a much higher
cost of care than say for instance Home
Health Care
in addition the prolonged pollen seasons
caused by climate change is resulting in
edmissions from people who suffer from
asthma and we all know that the tick
season is now longer the ticks are
living in greater numbers over the
winter because it's not as cold and so
this is causing increases in tick-borne
diseases such as Lyme and now new
evidence is linking the um
air pollution associated with burning of
fossil fuels with neurodegenerative
diseases such as Alzheimer's and
Parkinson's there's increasing evidence
supporting this link
so bottom line is we need to address
climate change and one way from
everything that I've studied is through
carbon pricing with cash back dividends
for individuals so that the average
consumer is not impacted by this but as
a whole we're factoring in the true cost
of burning fossil fuels into the cost of
the energy that we choose to consume it
as you've heard in prior testimony
encourages individuals to provide
additional
um
steps to keep their houses more energy
efficient I myself recently installed a
heat pump and am thrilled with the
significant reduction in my cost of
heating both through the complete
elamination of oil usage burning and a
reduction in my energy consumption so
those are examples New Hampshire needs
to prepare for carbon pricing and cash
back dividends by by studying the issue
as you've heard and I won't reiterate
too much that you know we need to be
prepared this is these are complex
policies I'm not only am I a nurse but I
have a master's in Business
Administration I worked 40 years in
corporate finance and accounting and
everyone knows that the better prepared
you are for significant change the
better off you'll be in accommodating
those changes I'd be happy to answer any
questions
thank you Barbara I mean yes um uh it's
okay
okay no questions thank you so much for
coming here
okay uh
Joan I'm sorry
a lot of names today I'm working my way
through here is as a substitute
I'm calling on Matt Stein next please I
think or Stern
hi I'm Matt Stein I'm from Northampton
uh representing myself
um
I think you've heard and you'll continue
to hear that having a price on carbon
that impacts every corner of New
Hampshire is a matter of when not if I'm
the CEO of a venture-backed weather
analytics company called Salient
predictions every day I work closely
with Business Leaders of some of the
world's largest companies and the energy
Insurance manufacturing and agriculture
sectors
I can tell you from personal
conversations with them that are also
corroborated by numerous surveys that
companies in the U.S overwhelmingly
support a price on carbon because it
drives Innovation which will transform
our economy and create new jobs
even carbon intensive businesses like
oil and gas are not only supportive but
are lobbying for a carbon price take
American petroleum Institute as an
example
that said we need to understand the
impacts on New Hampshire's residents
businesses and municipalities most
studies demonstrate that the impacts on
carbon pricing are overwhelmingly
positive for residents and businesses
but there may be a handful of
challenging situations
like serving certain carbon intensive
small businesses that frankly may be
difficult to quickly green
um case in point my brother-in-law is a
third generation lobsterman what will
that mean to his business we need to
identify those situations and come up
with potential solutions to limit any
adverse impacts to them
the good news is that there's a
tremendous amount of research and
modeling that has been done on carbon
pricing and this is not just academic
but lessons from Real World
implementations like are happening in
Canada
we can learn from these and make sure
that our citizens are prepared
we do not want to be caught flat-footed
when Federal carbon pricing legislation
discussions really take off so now is
the perfect time for New Hampshire to
thank you a couple of interesting points
here thank you for bringing those up
so you know other questions you're
next I'll call on
met
Callahan
it says here you have written testimony
good morning everybody
um thank you chair and members of the
committee from for hearing me today my
name is Matthew K Elaine I live in
Concord New Hampshire I have for the
last 30 years and I support this bill
um as a relevant background I worked um
within the division of Public Health
Services here for over 30 years both uh
and also in the in the private sector as
a consultant
um primarily looking at Environmental
Health Data how do you bring together
what we see out there for environmental
exposures and the health outcomes for
the last 10 years I specifically worked
under a CDC climate Grant looking at how
do we research and understand this and
then how do we build resilience so for
this specific bill
um that I'm supporting the reasons are
really that under the the first section
on findings it really talked about how
we needed to study carbon pricing right
we need to get out there and get in
front of it to understand it better and
get market-based um uh climate
protection and reducing of health and
economic impacts I believe we need this
to study commission to better assess how
to keep New Hampshire and America
competitive different changing
environmental and economic conditions
I believe in section two of them on this
bill they could be improved by adding
members that has a training experience
in public health impacts of
environmental exposures extreme weather
and climate change determining the
relationship between weather climate and
various Health outcomes is very
challenging and complex I've spent 10
years and I'm just getting a sense for
some of the things you heard mentioned
here around Lyme disease respiratory
exposure saying to that sort and there's
good news right we've done very well as
a nation improving our air quality and
water quality and people should know
about that there's a part in the bill
that states in section 2 part 4B the
commission still study the effects such
pricing would have on public health
including morbidity mortality effects on
reducing greenhouse gases and such if
that remains an essential activity in
this commission then Public Health
expertise will be very beneficial so in
conclusion I support the bill and I
support any efforts that we have to keep
New Hampshire in America more
competitive and resilient to these
significant changes we have coming so
that's it for my testimony thank you
seeing no questions thank you for coming
and testifying I appreciate it thank you
I have for my last speaker uh Mr John
Gage that will will give his two-minute
testimony
foreign
thank you chairman I actually asked for
15 because I believe
um I am the subject matter expert in
carbon pricing of at the federal level
and uh around the world I'm John Gage
from Windham
you will I appreciate if you could
shorten it down quite a bit we are on a
time schedule here okay I understand
thank you I will certainly try and we
know you John so
but I love talking carbon pricing and
this is a great opportunity thank you so
much for listening
um
so I support HB 372
here's one way to look at it if we had
known 10 years ago
um the prices Energy prices gas and oil
prices were going to spike last year
if we knew for sure or had a very high
likelihood of it happening 10 years ago
would we have done anything differently
yeah
or would we have just
let it happen
there's a lot of people hurting right
now from high electricity prices High
heating oil prices
they didn't think I better put
insulation in my house because energy is
going to get really expensive they
didn't replace their their bulbs
probably with LEDs maybe they bought an
oil furnace
two years ago thinking that oil is a
good way to heat my house that's going
to be another good way for 30 more years
well
carbon pricing is growing and spreading
around the world prices are going up 10
years ago there were 23 countries
pricing carbon
countries and regions today there's 68
countries and regions pricing carbon
it's tripled in 10 years and the prices
are rising Reggie was brought up
Reggie's averaged about five dollars per
ton of CO2 Emissions on fossil fuels
used to generate electricity
um which is about 20 of our greenhouse
gas emissions
but representative Nutter asked does
carbon pricing work to reduce emissions
and it's based on two things whether it
works or not what is the price
and how does the market believe that
that price is going to be stable or
what's going to happen to it in the
future
so
five dollars per ton of CO2 is not a
strong Market signal at all it's not
going to drive Innovation and Emissions
reductions what Reggie was doing for us
was raising money that we could reinvest
in Energy Efficiency and help low-income
households kind of prepare for the
transition transition it wasn't it
didn't drive down emissions 50 to New
but we do know what prices will do that
because this has been studied for
decades
the high Commission on carbon pricing
part of the World Bank
um and associated with that report that
was mentioned
um the first report
estimates we need a price of between 135
dollars per ton and thousands of dollars
per ton in 2030 in order to be on the
right emissions reductions path to
achieve the 1.5 missions temperature
Target that's a global price we need to
be minimum 135 dollars per ton around
the world in 2030.
Canada is going to be there they're
using carbon fee and dividends they're
at forty dollars now they're Rising
every year and they're going to be
Canadian 170 U.S 135 dollars per ton in
2030.
the EU price tripled in the last two
years
um they are now between 60 and 80 a ton
they're using a cap in trade so the
price varies but they'll certainly be
around 135 dollars a ton in 2030 also
and as was mentioned they'll be using
their c-bam
to charge their carbon price on energy
intensive Goods that are imported into
that Marketplace
it's not just going to be the EU other
countries like Canada are watching this
closely and economists call what's going
to happen a carbon Club
countries with similar prices will join
together and have no c-band between
those countries and trade
but other countries that don't have a
price on carbon will have to pay that
carbon price on Imports
the carbon Club is just going to keep
growing the e was starting at Canada the
UK and Japan are likely to join
um
of all the developed countries in the
world only two of them don't price
carbon right now
um
Australia did price it
now they're not pricing it but they'll
likely price it again it's one of the
problems is how do you keep the carbon
price there and permanent and durable
and that's where the cash back comes in
so Reggie spends most of the money or
returns most of the money it depends on
what's going on and it's got a low
carbon price it's around 13 per ton
right now
um
but a regional carbon price or a
straight carbon price doesn't have the
benefit of being able to use c-bam
so you can only go to a certain level
before you start to worry about pushing
your businesses to free polluting States
or regions
um
so
it's a good way to send a heads up to
your state or your region
um
that carbon pricing is coming from above
at the federal level at the federal
level we can put a steadily Rising high
price on carbon The Economist statement
that I passed out describes what's going
on
as a market failure it was described as
when the costs of pollution are not
included into the price of goods
then it can producers and consumers are
not completely informed by price and so
they don't make efficient decisions
in the case of pollution a third party
is being harmed and that harm is not
being accounted for in the market that's
why economists want to put a price where
the pollution enters the economy so that
The Guiding hand of the market the price
signal of the pollution is seen by
investors and producers and consumers
it's simply the most cost effective way
to reduce pollution comprehensively
throughout the whole economy charge coal
oil and gas producers a steadily Rising
carbon fee what you do with the money is
up to politics if you return it all back
to households most people come out ahead
I'm the state coordinator of citizens
climate Lobby a Grassroots organization
that is lobbying for bipartisan climate
policies at the federal level
why am I at the state level
I have Insight that I'm hoping
our state will use
to take advantage of anticipating a
can you sum up please yeah sure
so car there's Global carbon pricing
Trends it's spreading prices are rising
there's National carbon pricing Trends
the federal bill was introduced with
bipartisan bicameral support three
sessions ago it had several co-sponsors
the next time it was introduced it was
bipartisan the house it got up to about
75 co-sponsors last session it got up to
96 co-sponsors
um
it is a carbon fee and dividend bill so
why should our state study what the
impact of this would be on New Hampshire
well the longer we take to start placing
carbon at the federal level the steeper
we're going to have to rise that price
to meet to join that carbon club with
all of our trading partners
um we should do it as soon as possible
so that we can do what Canada is doing
and increase it a little bit each year
if we wait till 2030 and we have to put
135 dollars per ton price that's a
dollar 35 and a gallon of gasoline 10
cents per kilowatt hour in fossil fuel
electricity we don't want to do that
um is that your closing statement
so let me answer a couple questions
uh one was fine
um representative Nader said .002
percent she I think she's trying to
quote the amount of emissions that New
Hampshire contributes as far as the
country
um she's got her decimal point wrong
when you say percent you move the
decimal point over New Hampshire is two
is 0.2 percent of U.S emissions
um we're about half per capita what the
rest of the country is what does that
mean with a federal carbon fee and
dividend
we get more money back more money that's
being collected from other states
um the average household will be ahead
by a thousand dollars in year 10 with
the the dividend that's after paying all
of the higher prices
um do we need a commission that was your
third request so could you could you end
um proxy carbon pricing is being used by
hundreds of businesses and cities around
the country already
they're not pricing carbon they're
they're building a carbon price into
their books so that they make
forward-looking decisions so that when
the federal government does price carbon
they will not have made bad decisions in
the meantime do I buy an oil furnace or
a heat pump well if you know that the
carbon price is going to be 135 dollars
in 2030 and double that in 2040
and so on you will favor the heat pump
even though it's a little more expensive
it's going to save you a lot of money
over time and that's what we can do for
the state I don't like wasting money I
don't want our state to waste money we
need to do a bipartisan look at the
carbon pricing picture
and I'm sure that we'll decide it is
inevitable and take steps make a plan
and figure out how we can take save
money and use this insight to our
advantage there's lots of opportunities
that we can that we can do also thank
I have one question uh representative
partial
thank you chair and uh thank you for
taking my question
do I understand correctly maybe I have
the wrong take on this but do I
understand correctly that if we enact
carbon pricing will we be returning
money to Consumers if we do not intact
enact it we'll be setting it off sure in
the form of tariffs is that basically
how it's what we're talking about here
yeah
um you know the money is going to go to
other countries if we're not pricing it
here
um at some point it's just going to be
crazy for us to be paying all of our
trading partners
a carbon price so that we can allow
carbon pollution to be free in our own
economy
um we can get that money to households
by pricing carbon we make our businesses
more competitive in the global
Marketplace we have a carbon Advantage
right now the EU
cbam is going to be good for the United
States for the first couple years the
China has to pay three times as much of
a carbon fee and India will be paying
four times as much of a carbon fee in
the beginning but China has a carbon
price they will be decarbonizing and if
we don't decarbonize we have a
competitive Advantage right now so if we
put a price on carbon at the federal
level we'll keep that Advantage which
will pay off the rest of the century
thank you thank you yeah
seeing the other questions thank you
very much for your testimony Mr Gage and
seeing no other pink slips or speakers
I'm closing the public hearing on
372 and I'm asking representative
project to report the blue sheet results
and the online uh thank you chair on the
previous bill
House Bill 558
the blue sheet was none in favor one
opposed online it was 45 in favor
one opposed one neutral
on House Bill 372 the blue sheep was
nine in favor none opposed online was
171 in favor none opposed non-neutral
okay moving right along uh we are I will
now open
public hearing on
House Bill 509 and I believe represent
Harrington will be introducing the bill
graphic Jam here
all right thank you chairman uh I will
make this uh rather brief concealing
that we are in uh behind on schedule
here there's a series of these bills
that would affect the renewable
portfolios here uh um standard and what
I'm going to ask is that we retain the
bills so that they can be merged into a
single Bill uh I simply didn't have the
time to do this when I was trying to
sign off lsrs so I apologize for that so
I'm not going to get into a debate with
anybody on this I'm just saying that my
position is I would like to see the bill
and there'll be a couple of others
retained so that we can work up a
singular Bill and not waste everybody's
time on multiple bills that basically
address the same issue and I will not
take questions because there isn't any
questions
thank you very much for your short
testimony
I like it
uh okay well I will call on a uh let's
see do I have
a particular
cards here
good morning uh for the record my name
is Jason stock I'm the executive
director of the New Hampshire Timberland
Owners Association and I will be very
brief
um
giving the given the word that we just
heard that the bill will be sought to
retain we would support that motion we
don't support this bill and for all the
reasons that I had expressed to my
earlier testimony on house bills 160
165 166 that you heard earlier about
about the RPS and its impacts on biomass
markets and the forest products industry
and folks growing Timberland and trying
to manage Timberland so I will happy to
answer any questions but for the sake of
brevity I will leave it at that and uh
question from Mr uh Mr from a
representative Corman
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question uh so I mean this
bill actually would phase out the RPS
within four years
um
so
given given your position with the
Timberland owners what would you like to
see in terms of the RPS
we like the program we like the current
program we do not want to see it phased
out we we like the class structure we
like and we like the way it it currently
operates
thank you thank you and thank you for
Testimony uh calling next on Mr Griffin
Roberts
welcome to this committee
uh thank you members of the committee I
uh Griffin Roberts State energy program
manager at the department of energy
um I was just out in the hallway and
found out that uh the prime sponsor
indicated that he'd like to retain the
bill
um the department is neutral on the bill
as introduced but we did have some
observations I could go into that but if
the committee would like to move on I
will just take my seat in the back
anybody have any objection to Mr robors
moving on
good morning uh thank you
thank you for allowing me to speak on
behalf of standard power this morning
and as a resident of New Hampshire
I am opposing this bill as I fear it
will overall be holding New Hampshire
back in the energy sector the renewable
portfolio standard has allowed for
different types of energy to become
competitive with carbon Reliant energy
sources such as colon natural gas and
the renewable portfolio standard and
renewable energy fund have helped pave
the way for this positive change in our
Energy Mix
um I feel as though we would be putting
ourselves behind other states by not
embracing a cleaner energy future here
in New Hampshire and as a long time
citizen I want to see our state push the
envelope on new and cleaner Energy
Technologies and continue to annually
increase the renewable portfolio
standard which is why I oppose this bill
thank you and I'll accept any questions
well spoken
um you said long time resident how long
have you been 21 21 years born in Mass
raised in New Hampshire
thank you for being one of the Smart
Ones
any questions from anyone
no well thank you for coming appreciate
okay next I'm going to call on a uh
welcome thank you good morning and thank
you for allowing me to speak
um on behalf of standard power and as a
young person concerned about the energy
future of New Hampshire
um I'm opposing this bill because the
renewable portfolio standard and the
renewable energy fund are valuable
mechanisms for diversifying the state's
energy portfolio and ensuring a
resilient future for the grid
providing funding for renewable energy
development in New Hampshire allows for
another stream of domestic energy at
times when the supply chain for fossil
fuels is compromised and helps us
prepare for a more energy dependent
future in line with such Trends as
vehicle electrification by investing in
the expansion of Renewables now we won't
have to play catch-up later on and we
can be sure of a reliable power supply
in the future
um if anything we should increase the
RPS level to help build out a
distributed generation in New Hampshire
to keep up with electrification so thank
so you know questions thank you so much
I have the last speaker is Mr Nick
Krakoff
hey good morning my name is Nick
craigoff I'm with the conservation law
Foundation here in Concord I've also
submitted a written testimony as well as
a recent study by renew Northeast which
I encourage you to look at that is being
handed around right now the RPS benefits
New Hampshire's economy provides public
health and environmental benefits and
helps reduce energy rates by
diversifying New Hampshire's energy
generation I want to talk mainly about
the diversity benefits the energy
diversity benefits and how eliminating
the RPS would be a major step backwards
you know right in the RPS itself RSA 362
F1 it talks about how one of the
purposes of the RPS is to provide energy
diversity benefits which can which has
the potential to lower and stabilize
Future Energy costs by reducing exposure
to volatile fuel prices
and that's exactly what the RPS does the
higher electric rates that New Hampshire
is currently experiencing that's largely
the result of New Hampshire's over
dependence on natural gas for power
generation and for heating natural gas
prices are very volatile in contrast the
price of renewable energy is much more
stable
um and you know now it can cost even
less than than fossil fuel energy
sources so included in my in my
testimony attached there is a study from
a new Northeast and I would draw your
attention to um
Pages or slides 8 through 10 and 12
through 13 there
um
you know basically what those slides
show in that attached study is that
increased Renewables
um like offshore wind or even onshore
wind they provide a useful hedge against
volatile fuel fuel prices so when those
um you know what energy prices Spike
over the winter like where we've seen
this winter you know by having that
stable cost for for wind or offshore
wind that can really provide a hedge
against those volatile fuel prices
um you know also provides system
reliability benefits and then it also
has a price suppressing effect so you
know this is real evidence that
increased Renewables provide provide
benefits for for ratepayers and and um
you know New Hampshire's families and
businesses and can you know it's not a
cost on on people it's not going to
increase costs
um
Yeah so basically by eliminating the RPS
as this bill would do it would um make
New Hampshire residents even more
exposed to those volatile fuel prices
um and then finally you know as we're
aware the Renewables benefit the
environment and Public Health in New
Hampshire
so you know and some there's there's
numerous benefits from from Renewables
eliminating the RPS will be a big step
backwards and um yeah I urge you to itl
this bill I don't think retaining it is
is a useful Endeavor
um and thank you and happy to answer any
questions
thank you for your testimony and I'll
call on representative Corman
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question Mr Krakow
um regarding wind uh you say that the
prices are stable but I mean wind varies
in its intensity and also I just saw an
article in Bloomberg about actual wind
Mills um offshore blowing over so I mean
can we really say that that wind prices
are going to be stable well you know
unlike natural gas prices where you know
there's a market it's a commodity
you know the the price of that commodity
is based on whatever the market is doing
you know wind is an interminable
resource there's there's no you know
there's no there's no cost for them for
the marginal production of each extra
unit of wind you know it in some
instances the marginal cost can be let
can be less than zero because you're not
you know there's there's no market price
for for wind
um you know I'm unaware of the
when turbines blowing over um you know
and there's a lot of wind production in
the North Sea
um you know and that's been very very
successful for
the United Kingdom and Denmark and
Norway and those countries diversifying
representative Reynolds
thank you Mr chairman
um thank you Mr Krakow for being here
again
um I want to bring everyone's attention
to the to page 11 of of the handout that
you distributed and ask you to
elaborate a little bit more on what's
going on there this is
um the large state right next to us
Maine
uh puc
showing that they're already going out
for long-term contracts
for Renewal power can you just comment
sure I mean so but basically you know
this kind of shows the net benefits of
having power purchase agreements for
Renewables that this is for onshore wind
because there's no offshore wind in New
England yet but basically you know this
has tried to calculate all those
benefits you know mainly the
um the ratepayer benefits the cost
suppressing benefits from having those
additional resources on the grid and you
know there's been pretty significant
benefits to repairs already having those
extra resources on the grid from
existing onshore you know land-based
wind farms up in the northern part of
Maine correct yes
thanks
any other questions thank you so much
for your testimony seeing your other
speaker cards here
I'm going to close testimony on 509 and
thank you chair
House Bill 509 the blue sheet was none
in favor five opposed
online
two in favor
109 oppose one neutral thank you
thank you
with that said I'm going to
open up
our final bill for this morning which is
HB 523 and call upon the sponsor
representative partial
foreign
welcome
numbers
um the bill is about increasing our
definitely very limited from one to five
megawatts it wishes to make oh thank you
one Mega limit is an arbitrary barrier
so it's a five megawatt limit though for
the installer of a nameplate system that
does not exceed 4.99 name platin term
there are economics a scale that benefit
not only the generator but the entire
grid
grid decentralization allows load
reduction
the less Reliant we are on fossil fuel
and this is the surest way to break the
Monopoly of fossil fuel allowing Market
forces to once again benefit our rate
payers
uh the more we can flatten our Peak
capacity demand the more we can lower
energy costs that's that's one of our
major drivers and these alternate
sources while they do not work at night
as somebody May point out they work
during the day and they do work as load
reductions
um last year the long-awaited value of
distributed energy resource report the
VGA report
I concluded there's virtually no
significant cost shifting and not
metering in fact by reducing Peak demand
through the dispute energy we not only
lower transmission costs but also reduce
the peak demand and again resulting in
lower energy costs
a little bit of history in 2019 house
Bell 365 passed the house with what
should have been
a veto proof margin
after suno's veto with a bill in the
house failed to override The veto by 14
votes
we know and voters know that
diversification is the key to driving
our electric prices down
raising the net metering limit should
have been done years ago
and I deserve that our failure to
stimulate a diversified grid has
contributed to the higher fuel our
higher fuel costs
five megawatt system is not only more
cost efficient than a one megawatt
system but also a system that that size
is capable of powering something the
effect of 1 350 homes
in summary
the benefits of distributed energy
resource include lower cost Energy
System level capacity operating reserves
distribution distribution level capacity
and nut value to Dr grid like avoiding
infrastructure Investments improving
resilience and increasing integration of
clean energy
thank you
representative Harrington has a question
yeah I just said Thank you Mr chairman
I'm going to be taking my question
clarification you mentioned the report
that said there was no significant cost
shifting uh from net metering I believe
that was based on net metering one
megawatt and lower in fact they didn't
look it above one megawatt as your bill
proposes because there is none of that
allowed right now so would it be correct
to say that's only for below one
megawatt there was no significant cost
shifting I believe that would be oh
thank you for the question I believe
that would be correct but I also think
that we could extrapolate from that
report and also one other thing that
report did not take into consideration
was the current
we haven't cost of our energy
seeing your questions thank you so much
well next I'm going to call on our
illustrious orator and flamboyant
consumer Advocate Mr Donald crease
flamboyant
foreign I think I should probably stand
uh good morning honorable members of the
committee Mr Vice chair I'm Donald
crease the consumer advocate here to
testify in favor of House Bill 5 23 is
represented as introduced by
representative partial uh as he
indicated in his testimony the question
of raising the limit on net metering
from its current one megawatt up to
4.999 megawatts is a familiar subject
here at the legislative office building
and across the street at the state house
uh I I would like to draw your attention
to certain provisions of this bill that
the sponsor didn't mention which has to
do with the language on page two of the
bill beginning on line 23 and what that
language does is mandate that net
metering be treated as a load reducer
for purposes of how it is accounted for
on the elect on the electric grid and I
think that is a valuable bit of
legal clarification
that will benefit the state regardless
of what the net metering limit is
because when we treat
um net metering as a load reducer it
basically makes net metering invisible
at the bulk power level and saves a lot
of money on transmission
costs as a result and that is
likely to make net metering a much more
economical proposition from any
standpoint and therefore from the
perspective of the residential rate
mirror class that I represent a a very
good idea I I've never really talked
very much about the possibility of
increasing the net metering limit Beyond
one megawatt for the simple reason that
as far as I know there aren't any
residential customers in New Hampshire
who are likely to put three four or five
or four point nine nine nine megawatts
of net metering in their backyards that
that really is an industrial scale net
metering array and you would have to
have a very large backyard in order to
go beyond you'd have to have a large
backyard even to get to one megawatt as
a residential customer so in that sense
it's never really been my issue I will
say that the law consigns to the Public
Utilities Commission the responsibility
for determining what the just and
reasonable rate formula is for net
metering and I think because the vder
study has recently been completed and
because the consulting firm uh dunski
that did that study is about to update
it to account for the recent uptake in
Energy prices I I think that we can
reasonably depend on the Public
Utilities Commission to do a good job of
determining what the right way is to
compensate customers who choose to net
meter and so I think that's compatible
with the idea idea of increasing the
the limit up to 4.99 there is a little
bit of confusion that I'm having and it
might be because uh I'm just in in a
characteristic fog but at the very end
of the bill there's language about
grandfathering and
unless I'm mistaken the language is
backwards because it says that net
metering arrays that first become
operational on or after July first
became operational on or after July 1st
of 2019
uh our grandfathered whereas net
metering installations that became
operational before July 1 of 2019 are
not grandfathered and I think that might
be backwards unless I'm missing
something so that's something for you
all to consider depending on how you uh
treat the bill but I think it is worthy
of your favorable consideration uh and I
think that's about all I have to say
about it I would of course be happy to
answer any questions that the chair
would be willing to entertain
thank you representative Corman
thank you Mr chairman and always good to
see you Mr crease sorry that wasn't very
eloquent or uh entertaining
flamboyant I'm sure you'll do better
next time
um so I'm thinking about these
transmission costs
and when a net meter customer let's
let's say we have a net metering
customer who's netting out to zero so
let's say they over the period of time
uh in a billing cycle they produce one
megawatt hour but also consume one
megawatt hour from the grid
during the time that they're producing
they're putting money on money
electricity onto the onto the grid onto
the transmission lines as a as a
producer but during the time that
they're consuming they're actually
taking power from the grid as a consumer
so should they be charged transmission
charges for the time that they're
consuming
they are under the current net metering
tariff so in that sense it's a non-issue
what I like about this bill is to the
extent that that net metering customer
is discharging electricity into the grid
there's uh the practice of load
reconstitution where basically you tell
ISO New England that in fact that net
metering didn't happen that's eliminated
and I think that's good in terms of the
way that we determine what our states
and our utilities and individually our
customers reasonable share of
I have a question uh do you know
um
right now
who or what is not able to take
advantage of net metering under the
current
law does that include the was soon to be
the uh
Community grouping of
a system that's out there I forget the
exact name of it but you're talking
about Community power Community power
aggregation uh something like that or
are we talking industry or are we
talking General household residential
well as I said I don't think there are
any residential customers who are net
metering at the scale of three four or
five megawatts so I I think what you're
really looking at here is a provision
that would benefit frankly commercial
and Industrial customers who might be
interested in installing uh a bunch of
photovoltaic panels on the roof of their
Factory for example or their big big box
retail store or their commercial
property
so if I may have a follow-up so uh
I we were once told a few years ago that
one megawatt
basically would power a Super Walmart's
type store I don't know if that's still
current today but uh so in terms of that
um how many businesses do you think we
can attract if it was increased to say
two megawatts I I really don't know I I
apologize but uh generally I try not to
pay too much attention to the fate of
commercial and Industrial customers not
because I don't care about them because
obviously we want to have a viable
commercial sector in the economy but
because I have so much work to do just
keeping track of what happens to the
I knew the flamboyance would come out
there sooner or later
thank you uh representative Reynold
actually I representative Winnie Thomas
you're new here this morning so I'll
call on you first oh thank you very much
um
um thank you thank you for um Mr chair
and thank you for being here um Mr Chris
um I'm going to ask for a mini
historical lesson um if you could tell
me how the value of one Mega megawatt
was originally decided upon and was it
considered a safe number that is no
longer applicable to to today's
requirements
uh I that's a really excellent question
and I'm not necessarily the best
qualified person to answer it I will say
this since you asked for a historical
lesson uh net metering was invented by
accident back in I believe it was the
1970s by a guy who decided it was better
to ask for forgiveness than permission
down in Massachusetts so he wanted to
see whether if he wired up a bunch of
solar panels to his electric meter at a
big apartment building that he was
helping to develop whether it would run
them run the meter backwards he had no
idea and it turns out that it did and
initially it amused Boston Edison the
local utility because he was the only
person who tried it and it was just kind
of uh interesting from an engineering
perspective the utility started to get
really interested in this when it
started to significantly affect their
load and when lots and lots of people
started net metering and so what you've
had over time is public policy that's
been developed uh I don't want to say by
accident but iteratively and I think
that that one megawatt limit came in
during my Exile period I I hesitate to
admit this but there was an eight-year
period where I was exiled to a
neighboring state whose name I won't
mention
uh and at that time I think that you
know there was this arbitrary limit the
distinction made between net metering of
uh well the distinction is between 100
megawatts and one megawatt and then
there was this artificial constraint put
on one megawatt uh just as a way of
making sure that net metering didn't
grow in an unconstrained fashion because
just like that first fella wasn't sure
what would happen if he tried it we have
we've been hesitant about what will
happen to our grid if we let net
metering go uh Hog Wild Hog Wild being
representative Reynolds
thank you Mr chair I wanted to ask
you if you would let me
um not ask a question of Mr crease but
offer sort of a response to your
question
which is the type of building there's a
for example a large U.S Foods warehouse
I'll allow it shortly good thank you
thank you I mean a short explanation
guys there's a there's a large U.S Foods
warehouse down in Seabrook whose roof
would is such a large Warehouse that it
would accommodate
five megawatts of solar uh and there are
similar buildings in the state things
like FW Webb distribution warehouses uh
one can imagine you know Amazon
warehouses if they're being built that
could easily accommodate the scale of
generation that were contem that's
contemplated by this bill so sort of
more distributed generation
you know on at various points in the
grid right not to get into a discussion
I I'd be surprised to see any building
rooftop that could accommodate five
megawatts but we could probably talk
about that offline uh sure but um nope
okay
seeing no other questions thank you Mr
Chris thank you so much for putting more
entertaining next time all right I'm
sure
next I'll call on Mr Griffin Roberts
from doe Department of
energy
thank you chairman Thomas members of the
committee Griffin robers again strategy
program manager at the department of
energy the department of energy is
respectfully opposed to House Bill
2523 as introduced the bill Alters the
definition of customer generator and
statute currently statute defines a
customer generator as one with a total
Peak generating capacity of up to and
including one megawatt this bill would
allow a customer generator to be one
with a nameplate or maximum rate
capacity of anywhere less than five
megawatts the bill largely is a
reintroduction of past legislation
that's been considered in the past I
know the prime sponsor indicated House
Bill 365 for 2019 I think there was also
um do we uh respectfully believes the
bills proposed changes are a sizable
change to the state's net metering
statute
um we would respectfully contend there
would be more appropriate for the puc to
fully adjudicate its docket uh fully
adjudicate its docket de-22
-060 which is currently underway as the
puc considers amendments to the state's
net metering tariffs that are applicable
to customer generators we would
respectfully submit letting that process
play out before making sizable changes
to the state's net metering statute
um
with that that really concludes my
testimony I'm happy to take any
representative munz yes thank you Mr
chair
um we heard testimony this morning about
microgrids would expanding increasing
the capacity to five megawatts help in
the development of microgrids
thank you for the question
um
I don't know the answer
I would I would I would say potentially
yes but again I as I mentioned in my
previous answer is that there aren't any
real active microgrids operating in the
state so I can't look at anything as
kind of like a case example
um
I could dig into that a little bit
further but I think the answer I'm
representative Winnie Thomas thank you
Mr chair
um you say the doe is opposed to this
bill because it redefines the term
customer generator isn't that one of the
points of this Bill yes I thank you for
the question so
um I think in that statement I was just
defining broadly what the bill intended
to do
um
again our Our concern at least with the
bill is that there's just an active
docket underway that'll be fully
adjudicated with a number of
stakeholders I think the department
feels that letting that process play out
before making changes to the state's net
metering statute would be uh a good
approach to take for policy makers to
represent none oh no months
thank you Mr chair sorry I thought of
another question after uh you answered
my first one
um
except for the concerns that you
expressed about
um
uh you know the fact that this does
change
um
you know how we handled net metering and
and you know wanting to see the puc
process play out are there any concerns
at all that the department has you know
regarding the the capacity of the grid
to
um handle this I mean we hear a lot
about how you know there's concern about
expanding
um uh net metering because of the
potential impact on the grid I mean do
you folks share that concern yeah thank
you for the question so the department
of energy is an active participant in
the puc's docket
um again de
22-060
we feel that that process will allow for
a deeper vetting of that question rather
than just an independent party reaching
it itself again with the collaborative
group of stakeholders who can kind of
arrive at that decision that's done
thank you no other questions thank you
for your testimony thank you I'll call
on the last speaker
I would have seen that eventually I
guess
um my name is Paul button I'm a
independent monitor
certified by the New Hampshire puc since
2012.
I've been a licensed electrician in New
Hampshire and Massachusetts for close to
40 years
and my small business is in good
standing with the New Hampshire
Secretary of State
I have a client database of about 2 000
solar
PV arrays
and it makes
um my business kind of a Nexus
for folks taking advantage of the
relevant portions of
um
the RPS
so I support New Hampshire 523
um
that seeks to amend our RSA 362
from its current outmoded wording
to instead state that the name plate or
maximum rated capacity of five megawatts
less than five minutes
uh my my contention is that um leaving a
raise a larger than one megawatt
out as ineligible
will significantly decrease their
overall contribution
to the sustainability and the health of
the iso New England
electric grid
so we're not just talking about the
state we're talking about a regional
effect
um
in my opinion
this is an obvious attempt by the
regional grid operators to maintain
their business strategy of complete
control
of the supply of available power
and leaves the ordinary citizen of New
Hampshire
very little control
over the default costs of obtaining
sufficient power
and then these costs are passed on to
um and the latest puc approved rate
um
I would submit to any lawyers within
earshot that this is uh legalized
larceny
so I would I would ask our honorable
state representatives to dedicate
themselves to the work of the people
who elected them
and not be swayed by the arguments from
the army of lawyers and lobbyists that
have been deployed by the regional grid
operators
thank you for your testimony
we have a question from
between the two I'll start with
representative Reynolds
thank you Mr chairman
I'm thank you for coming here today
um just putting a face on the occupation
of the independent monitor who certifies
the Rex production of wrecks going into
the grid can you just comment I was
astounded when you said your Client List
exceeds 2 000 are there without you can
name names if you want but can you
characterize the are are there
characterize your client base are there
public entities on there yes school
systems yes uh County governments yes
municipalities yes
anymore those are good follow-up
questions yes thank you I think we'll no
that's okay do you want me to to give
you a kind of an overview or yes okay
capsule
um I do have several uh municipalities
sandwiched on a sandwich town at
wolfborough
um I also have some corporate uh clients
um one is a fairly large
they have uh respectively 200 megawatt
200 200 megawatt 200 kilowatt array and
a 400 kilowatt array
um and
I suggested to them that they maybe
don't need my services since they're so
big that they could do something called
Auto reporting which would be a simple
module add-on to their software that
would simply report to the National
Database that's the function that I do
and they said no no we want you to we
want you to do it I said Okay
um Comcast is also a client they have a
400 kilowatt array on their parking
garage
Pine Island Pond I think it is pylotted
um
so yeah I mean they
and then I also have one of my first
clients was actually Unitil
um the Exeter High School
and that is 100 kilowatt array
and size wise
um it's a it's a soccer field
little bit bigger than a football field
so size wise if you want to get what a
one megawatt
array would be
you can effectively multiply that
football field a soccer field by 10. so
you know the the idea of having
a lot of land in the backyard well yeah
it would take a lot of land to put
something up like that
thank you I'm going to go to the okay
I'm sorry uh well representative
Harrington you're uh your next yeah I'm
just trying to uh get a little bit more
about where you're coming from on this
your background it sounds and correct me
if I'm wrong but it sounds as if your
business would increase and your profits
increase if this bill would pass yeah
this this is true I'm not here to
promote my business promote the
well-being
and physical stability of the of the
citizens of New Hampshire
period
okay representative munz
of um thank you Mr chair thank you for
uh coming in and giving us your
perspective
of your ex within your existing client
base are there clients that have
expressed to you a desire to want to
expand Beyond
what oh sure now you have to understand
a majority of my clients are
residentials okay so ordinary folks
um
and the the average size of of the array
is about uh 10 kilowatts is that that's
fairly big as far as a residential
install
um
but again it runs through the range so
people might start off small and I
caution people that
um anything less than five kilowatts is
really kind of it I mean it's it's worth
it it's the problem is is that
um okay
a raise less than five kilowatts will
produce renewable energy certificates
very slowly so they're not going to see
that return on investment immediately so
I just try to you know make sure that I
set their expectations up front
um so
yeah and they they do they when they see
that they can make a few dollars it's
not a lot of money
thanks to the efforts of
the utilities
um they've nibbled away at the value of
the wrecks over the years when I started
the business
um the wreck's worth about 55 dollars a
piece now they're going for about 30.
and they were down as low as five
dollars a piece thank you
all right uh I think uh we've asked
enough questions of this gentlemen uh I
think it's time to move on thank you so
much so very enlightening on what you do
very good I'm going to call our our last
speaker of the morning Mr
Nicholas Leiden or Linden Leyden
ah
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to speak this morning
um with IBEW Local 490 we're the inside
Wireman local for New Hampshire
um
I wanted to speak specifically to this
bill uh on
not just the environmental impact of
increasing generation but the jobs
impact
uh we do have Associated Grocers over in
Pembroke we did a uh an array on their
facility
we could only do one megawatt it
basically is a giant refrigerator they
use a ton of power over there we could
have gone bigger but it they wouldn't
have gotten any net metering out of it
so it didn't make any sense so
I'd say about a quarter of their roof
was filled and the rest is vacant
um
they're not the only one another one of
our customers Anheuser-Busch out of
Merrimack has for years talked about
wanting to put a solar array down there
to offset their operating costs they
just can't build one big enough
to offset enough to make it worthwhile
for them
um
we've done a lot of schools we did the
Dover school which at the time was the
largest Rooftop in the state
they could have gone a little bit bigger
but
it was about as big as we could go on
their roof uh
you've got other businesses like Lawns
Pharmaceuticals down in Portsmouth that
have talked about doing a large solar
array these are
yes they're not your homeowners but
there are a good number of industrial
scale and Commercial scale facilities
out there that are interested in putting
large systems on there and
speaking of Anheuser-Busch they've had
cutbacks on their
their budgets for this year so there are
people over there that are working that
aren't getting a full 40 hours
it's an assumption but if they had an
array that was lowering their operating
costs they might not have to cut back on
those workers as much so you'd be saving
in other ports of their other parts of
their their budgets
um
usually the going trend is to give
corporations tax breaks to help them
grow and to help them succeed
this is essentially giving them a break
that is not in the form of a tax break
but it is going to lower their operating
costs and allow some of these businesses
the opportunity to expand in the future
with the savings that they would get
from these systems
thank you uh Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question just so we're clear
there's nothing that prevents anybody
from building something larger than one
megawatt they just can't do it with net
metering for instance I think Fidelity
put in one that was I believe it was
over 10 megawatts they had I don't know
12 acres of solar panels which I guess
turns out to be about three or four
megawatts somewhere in that vicinity so
it certainly can be done you just don't
be able to take you don't be able to
sell the electricity back through net
metering but there's nothing that
prevents an industry from putting up 50
megawatts if they wanted to
is that correct
I believe that there are actually
restrictions on the total size of array
in the state
I don't believe we build arrays that are
over
um five megawatts right now at least I
haven't seen one that's gone through
commercially
they were over 5 megawatts would have to
be metered through ISO New England as a
generator but they could still be built
correct
representative
McWilliams
thank you chair um and thank you for
your testimony today I think this is
really helpful for us to understand the
face of of the folks who are facing some
challenges here I want to understand a
little bit more about
um
what it would look like for a facility
that currently has one megawatt and
would like to expand to say three
megawatts and can't because they're
capped at one Meg while right now
although this enabling bill would allow
4.99 is there anything that's uh
that would need to be accounted for to
do a second project or was the first
megawatt the only bite at the Apple
that's really allowed just in terms of
expansion so I can understand how the
market works
I mean in terms of yeah in terms of
expanding
um
these buildings are already designed
with their services to consume enough
power to power themselves so if they are
offsetting their costs directly then
they already have the infrastructure
there you just have to add more of an
array more inverters but the the
infrastructure is already there for them
to kick that amount of power back onto
the grid so for a lot of these companies
it was just a matter of they wouldn't be
offset the net metering
to go bigger than the one megawatt that
they did follow up
follow up
um so so for some of these really large
facilities
they're not current ly using
they're not currently creating their
Macs for the the amount that they need
therefore they're still paying the usual
electric charge rather than net metering
because they just can't get where they
need to get to to potentially completely
cover the load and it sounds like that's
really the challenge here is that we
have large corporations that are
struggling and are dealing with you know
100 increase on their electric bills and
maybe that means layoffs right in the
case of he said Anheuser-Busch so this
could be seen as a potential business
enabling Bill to allow them to do what
they need to do to cover those electric
costs
um have you seen any facilities that are
doing this on parking lots
um I know we talked about the size of a
backyard you know you need something
like 25 acres for five minutes could we
could we shorten it to a question please
yeah absolutely so can you just explain
if you have some folks in your stable
who would be able to expand Beyond
rooftop to parking lot or other
Alternatives that they've looked at
because I think we're really limiting
ourselves when we say it's a yard
correct yes uh Anheuser-Busch would not
be a rooftop facility they would have to
build an array on the property off of
their rooftop
um there are some other large
manufacturing I mean Associated Grocers
is just an enormous building so they'd
be able to satisfy their needs on their
roof but there are other
corporations out there that have land
adjacent to their area where they could
build a a ground Mount array to offset
their costs also thank you
um if there's different questions I'll
take one more I think we've establish
the fact that there are a lot of
entities out there that would like to
take advantage of net metering if they
were could be allowed to build a larger
array and and sell more electricity back
to the power companies which in turn
have to accept that as part of their
cost of doing business but is there a
different question to have a question
representative Summers okay go ahead
thank you Mr chairman I believe this is
different
um so if I'm wrong please forgive me
um
if I understand correctly and I'm just
going to ask you a question on this with
the corporation as you mentioned
Anheuser-Busch went up to four megawatts
if this bill did not pass and the limit
for net metering was still one megawatt
with four megawatts would they still
would they not still be able to save
money on their electric bill with the
so you're saying under current terms
with the one megawatt would they still
if they were gen I'm sorry I don't know
um if they are if they build four
megawatts of solar panels and they're
utilizing it for their business would
that not lower their electrical cost
generating four megawatts of power for
their business even if this bill stayed
they would still be able to build an
array of that size uh as far as my
knowledge on what you get more for as a
power generator or as Net Zero that I'm
not as familiar as some other people
with but I know from the conversations
that we have had with them they would
if if I may for clarification the way I
understood it let's say the company
let's say their business only uses one
megawatt and they don't intend to expand
so let's say they go they they they're
always applying all their power with one
megawatt but if they build a four
megawatt array
they don't need an extra megawatt to run
their business but they would be able to
sell it back to the edge company if we
were to pass this bill
otherwise they wouldn't be able to sell
it back correct
and yeah as far as access for Net Zero
that I'm not as familiar with
um I know the issue that we've run into
with them is that they need more than
one megawatt in order to offset their
total operating costs
um
I don't know rates as far as if you
exceed what you can produce what you'll
get back
um
that part of it I'm not as familiar with
okay what I'm I'll talk offline thank
you uh it's
um operating costs versus their
electricity costs could be two different
things but I'll I can talk to you
offline
so you know other questions thank you so
much
and having no other bills
no other speakers
I'm closing HB 523
and we'll ask for the blue sheet report
from representative closure
thank you chair
House Bill
523 the blue sheet was five in support
none opposed online
do 65 in support two oppose no neutral
thank you thank you uh so 11 30 not bad
for the bills we had this morning I
appreciate
the cooperation that this is good we
will break for lunch and we will come
back at one o'clock for an announcement
and for some discussion and I'll uh so
you'll have to wait till then to to know
what I mean thank you so much enjoy your
lunch
foreign
good afternoon everybody I want to
so we're here this afternoon for an
executive session at one o'clock
but before we begin that we have a
couple of announcements I'd like to call
on representative McWilliams for an
announcement thank you so much chair
Vose I'd like to give an update to the
committee regarding
um ranking member Kat McGee as you all
may know she's been out for health
reasons
um and uh she had a very successful
surgery and she's officially cancer
clear lymph nodes are negative so she's
in a really great spot right now for
recovery and we're looking forward to
seeing her hopefully fingers crossed in
four weeks or so if everything goes well
with her health so this is really
exciting that she's cancer-free right
now I just wanted to share that with
everyone
that is wonderful news thank you
representative McWilliams representative
Doug Thomas also has an announcement hi
a couple things one I just want to
remind everyone we'll be having a
subcommittee meeting on Wednesday for
um the HP 81 on the propane Bill uh the
um uh folks are going to have a couple
of reps here from AmeriGas which we'll
talk about uh their um
their situation and also some corrective
action that they are proposing they'll
also be members from at least three
other propane companies here as well to
um answer questions about uh charges and
and things like that
so uh everybody is welcome to come uh in
addition to the subcommittee members
that's that one the second one is I just
want to have a uh either show of hands
or not a support whatever we have an
opportunity coming up here uh in a
couple of weeks for when we have the
week off and uh although I won't be here
after uh March 2nd There's an
opportunity for maybe a Monday or a
Tuesday if anyone would like to have
some additional education presentation
one of the suggestions that was made to
me was maybe having a presentation here
on more of the details on net metering
or maybe a presentation on on the report
that was sent out on net metering and
the costs involved of it to maybe a
little more depth of information we
might be able to offer that or we could
offer whatever else someone else might
choose that they they may want to so the
first question would be if anyone would
like to be here on that week that we
have no committee meeting if there's
interest in that then we can proceed you
can we can have a preliminary show of
hands now if anybody would want to be
here on that Monday or Tuesday and he I
know I could be
seems Seems like there'll be enough
people that we could
present something so we'll we'll ask
about that first or some other subject
that might be better and then be
thinking about the springtime when we
may this is when we traditionally make
some uh trips
in the past we've we've been to the more
Dam up Beyond Littleton to look at the
Hydro power we've been to uh we haven't
been to the natural gas plant in
Londonderry in well over four years that
might be an option Seabrook is always an
option they get they give a great tour
there
there are several solar
arrays that we could visit
um you can look at glass I guess and and
see uh how they set up their their
system there or something else that
might uh be good that affects our
committee so be thinking about that as
well uh because we need to plan for that
any questions
okay that's it
all right thank you one quick last
announcement we have a card here we're
going to pass it around we'd like you
all to sign it we're going to send it to
John lewicki to wish him uh continued
success in his recovery
we now have an address where you can
send cards I sent that out over the
weekend to all members and if you'd like
to send your own personal card feel free
to do so
but we will send a card from the
committee
so with that now we can begin the
business of executive sessions so I'm
going to open an executive executive
session on House Bill 175.
and call on representative Thomas for a
motion
and Mr chair uh I motion to retain HP
175 representative Bernardi is
recognized I second that motion
it's been moved and seconded that we
retain House Bill 175 is there any
discussion
representative Corman
thank you Mr chairman I'm just curious
uh what do we hope to accomplish by
retaining it
typically when you retain a bill you
hold on to it over the summer and then
in the fall you discuss it again to see
if there is anything that can be done
relative to the subject of the bill and
so that would be the purpose of routine
follow-up follow-up yeah so I mean that
I understand the question is for the
specific bill I mean we were told that
the greenhouse gas target has already
been met so I don't understand what
could be further gained by retaining the
bill
I'm not sure either but that's always
what uh the investigations in the fall
seek to reveal if there is anything
representative McWilliams
thank you chervos to follow up on
representative corman's comment I think
there is an opportunity if we retain
this bill to strengthen the goals
um perhaps to increase our Target
numbers for uh State departments to
reduce fossil fuels and also potentially
to add fleet vehicles as part of the
greenhouse gas goals targets so I think
there's something here I think we could
probably work on it if we chose to do so
as a committee thank you
any further discussion on the motion to
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll on the question of retain for
Doug Thomas
yes Janine nodder yes
okay
Carol Brown yes Lex bregini yes JD
Bernardi yes Tom blochet yes James
Summers yes Rebecca McWilliams yes
Joan Hamlet yes
uh
Carey speyer
yes Lucia's partial yes Melanie Kaplan
yes Chris muns
yes
Henry Noel
Wendy Thomas yes
Thomas Corman yes
chairman Vose yes
so 18 to Zero by a vote of 18 to zero
House Bill 175 is retained by the
committee
so I'll close the exact session on House
Bill 175 and remind the committee that
we will not be discussing this bill
again until the fall
now with that I'll now open an exact
session on House Bill 176 relative to
the rules of the site evaluation
committee and recognize representative
Thomas for a motion
okay
yeah
oh I was working yours for a while so I
uh I make motion for wage view 176 to
retain
representative Bernardi I second the
motion it's been moved and seconded that
we retain House Bill 176 is there any
discussion
representative McWilliams
press the record this one is in regards
to the rules for the site evaluation
committee I do think that we have some
opportunities to make this a stronger
bill as well I also think that we could
have some interesting testimony if we
chose to from Gel car to understand
exactly how the current legislation and
rules work and see if there are
redundancies or potential conflicts so I
think there's some work to be done here
and I think it would be good to retain
I would Echo representative McWilliams
comments that there is further work to
week or so can't remember the exact date
a major Bill to reorganize the site
evaluation committee and it might be
better to hear that bill before
proceeding further with this bill which
would be another reason to retain it
so that would be I think a worthy
recommendation for this committee any
seeing none I asked the clerk to call
the role on the question of retain for
house bill 176.
Doug Thomas yes
Janine nodder yes
Carol Brown
Lex barajny yes JD Bernardi yes Tom
plushie yes James Summers yes Rebecca
McWilliams yes
Joan Hamlet yes Carrie Speer yes Lucia's
partial yes
Tony Kaplan yes Chris muns yes Henry
Noel yes Wendy Thomas yes
Thomas Gorman yes Ned Reynolds
yes chairman of owes yes
18-0 by a vote of 18 to nothing House
Bill 176 is retained in committee
and will not be dealt with again until
this fall after September
and with that we'll close the public
hearing on House Bill 176.
exact session rather
always get those two mixed up in my mind
okay so now we'll open an exact session
on House Bill 208 FN which establishes
greenhouse gas emission reduction goals
for the state and establishes a climate
action plan
and at the call of the chair we're going
to recess this exact session until
and now I'll open an exact session on
House Bill 298 relative to placement of
personal wireless service facilities
and at the call of the chair I'm going
to recess this executive session until
and sadly that concludes the work of the
committee until 2 30 this afternoon so
if you haven't had lunch yet now's your
chance to go grab a bite to eat
otherwise we'll see you back here at 2
okay good afternoon everybody time for
us to get back to work
so I'm going to call to order a public
hearing on House Bill
524--fn relative to Regional greenhouse
gas initiative funds
this bill is sponsored by Kat McGee the
ranking member who is out as we all know
on
medical leave and so
standing in for representative McGee
this afternoon will be representative
Chris munz to introduce the bill Chris
it's all yours
thank you members of the committee happy
Saint Valentine's Eve
if like me you've forgotten to buy a
card don't make sure make sure to stop
stop off at the drugstore on your way
home
um for the record my name is Chris munz
I am one of Hampton's four state
representatives serving in Rockingham
County District 29. our colleague
representative Kat McGee asked that I
introduce HB 524 and read the following
testimony from her
chairman Voss and his team colleagues at
the house senate technology and energy
committee I'm sorry that I am unable to
be with you today but I am pleased to
present HB 524 for your consideration
as long as I have been on stne there has
been division around the proper use of
Reggie funding in the state of New
Hampshire
I believe we are missing an opportunity
to lower our overall demand and prevent
the sunk costs that come from
large-scale dirty fuel infrastructure
when we Fritter away the value our state
derives from being part of the regional
greenhouse gas initiative
in recent hearings I asked Des to
confirm what I had read about other
participating States using on average 80
percent of their Reggie auction proceeds
for investments into lowering their
imported fuel dependence
we have continued to debate whether all
the money should be distributed as a
bill credit when in fact the economies
of scale that are intended By Reggie are
the biggest savings we could Supply to
all rate payers
we currently invest less than a tenth of
what our regional our regional Reggie
Partners invest
I was surprised to learn that before the
quarterly auction proceeds were changed
in statute to provide all but one dollar
to Bill credits
the legislature had agreed to invest the
first six dollars of the proceeds
so in the instance of a 13 dollar
auction credit six dollars would go to
bring overall demand down thereby truly
lowering energy costs for everyone and
allowing the state to manage programs
with sufficient funding to gain real
savings
and the remaining seven dollars would
continue to be reimbursed as consumer
bill rebates
but knowing how our committee feels
about this funding I am proposing that
we only reinstate half of that six
dollars in a compromise that says we can
do a lot of good and declare it a
victory by passing a bill that requires
the first three dollars go into the doe
Energy Efficiency accounts to allow us
to advance in meaningful ways
HB 524 says that we can do several good
things without sacrificing the concept
of direct help to electric bills we can
triple the doe funding to Energy
Efficiency and renewable and sustainable
energy projects by contributing the
first three dollars of the current 13
Reggie allowance leaving ten dollars per
allowance to continue to help with
consumer bills
because of the rate of growth of the
auction allowances we are still
contributing a significant amount of
money to all consumer electric bills
however when we originally agreed to one
dollar per allowance to help lower
demand that was 50 percent of the
allowance our current investment is 7.7
percent
one dollar out of 13 and 92.3 percent of
the funding disappears onto bills this
is wasteful
HB 524 asks that we increase our
investment to three dollars per auction
share and settle on an investment ratio
of 23 percent
returning 77 percent by putting ten
dollars per auctions share into the
pockets of rate payers it's a way to
gain the true value of the program
without sacrificing the help to build
to Bill payers in this tough time
if auction prices continue to increase
then the amount of help to offset
efforts also increases consumers lose
nothing but the state gains the ability
to do more to help lower costs
without some investment in changing the
energy picture in New Hampshire we will
be doomed to repeat last Fall's rate
hikes it is time we made this program
work for the people of New Hampshire
so we have something to show for our
years of participation
I ask for your support on of this
conservative Bill to gain a win for the
people of New Hampshire thanks for your
time
that concludes the testimony that
representative McGee asks that I share
with you
I am happy to try to answer any
thank you representative munz Mr
chairman before we proceed we've got it
I got a note from representative McGee
actually she says that the stream the
live stream of our committee is not it's
not working it's not on serious
second
okay Christy our committee researcher
assures us that the live stream is
working so if you hear differently from
representative McGee let us know
it might be something on her her end
rather than oh no
our end
so back to where we were representative
muns thank you for introducing the bill
you told me earlier not to ask questions
uh are you sure you still want to take
questions
I stand by my comment that I will try to
answer questions okay questions for
seeing none looks like you're off the
hook
we take care of our own
all right
Let's uh let's bring forward now
Josh Elliott from the Department of
energy to give us his perspective on
foreign
Mr chairman uh members of the committee
for the record Josh Elliott director of
the division of policy and programs the
New Hampshire Department of energy the
department is neutral on this bill
um I think representative munz through
uh representative McGee's testimonies
are laid out exactly what the intended
impact of this bill is and the sort of
intended goals
um the only thing the department would
add um just refer you to the fiscal note
which was done jointly by Des and doe
and I mean by jointly I mean Des did
much of the heavy lifting on this one
for our review
um the the cumulative rate impact just
purely the rate impact would be about
6.4 million dollars obviously that would
be then offset by any of the benefits
that we accrued to the folks who would
receive
um
Energy Efficiency uh projects done that
are funded through these through this
through these funds so with that I'm
happy to take any questions the
committee has
thank you very much questions for Mr
Elliott representative Nate Reynolds has
a question
thank you Mr chairman
um
Mr Elliott with with the relatively low
amount of funding that currently goes
into the Energy Efficiency fund
the way things are now
it's just a dollar from each allowance
auction can you shed any light on the
um
stability of of
funding and how often
folks who contact the New Hampshire
saves program
to seeking seeking funding for Energy
Efficiency measures in their home or
business how often
are they told
you know we're out of funds
um wait you know we'll take your
application but uh we gotta wait for the
fund to be refilled
um thank you very much for the question
excuse me thank you very much for the
question
um
as you know with um House Bill 549 from
last session
um with the uh
puc order prior to that there was
certainly a lot of uh instability in the
New Hampshire saves programs just
generally
um
I believe a lot of the uh sort of
uncertainty has been worked out of the
system from that I think they've been
dealing with the backlogs they've gotten
their programs set up a lot of that has
sort of worked its way through there are
a couple of other different uh buckets
of funding that folks who are looking to
get assistance will go to whether it's
directly from the systems benefits
charge through the uh hea funds which is
low income funds the department also
runs the weatherization assistance
program we also have additional funding
from the bipartisan infrastructure law
for additional funds
um
so just to get you give you a sense of
sort of the larger funding picture out
there
um in terms of the waitlist by specific
utility territory if they exist and how
long they take to get off a wait list if
one does exist
um I think would be better directed to
the utilities rather than than us so
sorry that's a long story not answer
answer
saying none I want to thank you for
being here
to give us your perspective on this Bill
thank you very much Mr chairman
and we'll Now call forward Mr Joe
Fontaine from the Department of energy
to give us his perspective
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee
for the record my name is Joe Fontaine I
represent um
Environmental Services Des
uh Des takes no position on the bill but
I did um
circulate just prior to the hearing a
chart that I think is
handy
um first page goes over
um
allocation of the revenue under current
law
and if you assume that 43 million goes
into the fund as was the case last year
um and 3.21 million allowances
are allocated
then uh that's what goes to uh 3.21
million would go to the Energy
Efficiency programs
so that and the remainder of 39 plus
million would go to Great payer rebates
that's under current law
as was mentioned verbally
by representative munz
um three times
the current amount would go to Energy
Efficiency programs or
9.63 million
which is which matches the amount that's
in the fiscal note that's attached to
the bill
and the amount of rebates would be
reduced to 33 million
um
when I handed this out I got the
comments that you've seen this before
you did see this a similar chart for
House Bill 418
um and under that bill if you remember
that did away with the rebates and
um all of the revenue went to Energy
Efficiency
so this bill is is uh
increases the amount to Energy
Efficiency
and and lowers the amount of rebates as
compared to current law but it is not as
ambitious as house bill 418.
that's all I I have take questions thank
you very much appreciate your testimony
did you participate in the creation of
the table that's on the back page of the
fiscal note
yes we completed a fiscal note worksheet
jointly with Department of energy as
Josh said and um
you as you know
um legislative budget assistant actually
does the
write-up of the fiscal note but it's
basically yes that's what we sent to
them so in your judgment is this table
correct
yes yes oh okay great did you find the
description it's accurate from what was
in the chart okay thank you for other
questions for Mr Fontaine uh Tony Kaplan
representative Kaplan thank you Mr chair
and thank you Mr Fontaine for coming uh
today
um do you have any idea of the impact of
an increase in Energy Efficiency funds
on air quality does your department make
any estimation of that
uh
Reggie is uh
IT addresses climate change
secondary benefits are that if you
reduce carbon dioxide you also reduce
co-pollutants
that would have an impact on
health
there have been reports in the past
as to how much benefit there has been
oh the Name Escapes Me Now of the
organization that did it
uh but um
quite large estimates of uh impact on on
health
follow-up yeah thank you Mr chair is
there any way you could provide that to
the committee at some point that'd be
additional questions representative
Reynolds has a question thank you Mr
chairman uh I'm along the same lines the
regional grid operator showed us a graph
that
showed that behind both behind the
meters solar and Energy Efficiency had
significantly depressed
total Regional demand
and therefore
has had a
beneficial Financial effect on lowering
lowering prices on on the grid and
saving consumers money so
um
I don't know rather than I don't want to
ask you to do the economic analysis on
that but
with increased investment in Energy
Efficiency as this bill contemplates be
expected to produce
savings for all customers in New
Hampshire
through reduction of regional demand
yeah in in past sessions we've testified
regarding
the transmission costs associated with
the bill
with the electricity bill
the house bill and
um so transmission costs uh
each state in New England shares in
those costs proportional
to their load and um
so if the other states
are reducing load because they're
investing in Energy Efficiency and their
load is going down as shown on that
chart
and actually if you look at
individual State charts for that and
compare
New Hampshire's I'm not sure the most
recent but in the past it's been almost
flat
rather than that difference so
um
because we don't invest as much in
Energy Efficiency
so
um
further investment in transmission costs
for the region
if our proportion goes up slightly
and the rest of the states go down then
seeing none I want to thank you Mr
Fontaine for giving us your perspective
and for giving us an updated chart on
the Reggie Revenue allocation
I have no other pink cards for this
public hearing is there anyone else who
would like to speak with the honorable
John Mann like to come up and address
good to see you John thanks for making
microphone on
it's worth it thank you very much for
being willing to listen I am I think I
want to pass out a
homemade flyer
I'll start with that I'll start with
that chart I was just deciding that I
would um
the value of Energy Efficiency in
returning
um wealth to the community
in other words you know on a family
basis of course if you have a more NHA
efficient house it's not your your
heating bills and your electric bills
which are part of that will go down so
uh I happen to have too much experience
with a very nice house
um
it was 37 below the other day and in at
7 A.M on Sunday and it was 67 in the
house
that's 104 degree difference it's the
insulation in the house that made that
difference
we heat with a heat pump which is kind
of slow and it kind of was kind of
oozing a little bit wisp of heat in the
floor so that's overnight Heat
um
our town library we had a woman named
Margaret Dillon who was an expert
auditor she has infrared equipment and
she would put a blower door and suck air
out of the library on a particular door
and you can go around and see where all
the cold air is coming in in there with
an infrared camera
combined with a typical
two-picture camera you know exactly
where the air is coming and you don't
know what to do
and we cut the cost by about 58 percent
and we did that with some pretty radical
work
but even before that just by sealing two
hatches where air could go from the main
floor up to the first attic and up to
the upper attic which is fully open to
the outside
we could cut we cut the heat by 20
percent
and just that work alone got the town
voted
thirty thousand dollars to complete the
rest of the
project so that's pretty effective
what I've passed out is my study work I
just decided to look into the issue of
um return on investment if you return if
you um
if you insulate a bunch of houses one
after another or a bunch of buildings or
you do an increased amount of energy
efficiency
what happens is the results of that work
are permanent it's not like lighting a
furnace and burning oil you're just
making an absolutely permanent change to
the building and reducing its rate of
Need for energy
and every time so from then on for the
remainder of the duration of that
building it is saving that much
money and that much fuel every year
then you do your second Year's work in
an Energy Efficiency program Statewide
and there's another stream
of savings and then another and another
and if you graph that what you get is a
parabolic increase or an accelerating
increase in the amount of money saved
for a linear amount of investment that
means there's a break-even point
and that explains finally why some of
these other states have been so
successful
you know I mean
poor Boston they have Harvard Business
School and all these other places right
next door breathing down their neck so
of course they understood all these
potentials they had all kinds of models
to look at and so on
um so I think that's I think it's
something that we should realize that
there will be a break-even point that
competent management and competently
getting through the learning curve
will get us to this Breaking Point
earlier
uh than it would have we just
lackadaisically throw some money at
Energy Efficiency
is money going into the economy
sufficient to pay for the remainder of
the program
and that's what my chart seems to say it
says that to me
so it's like a no-brainer to go Whole
Hog on Energy Efficiency so that's the
main point I wanted to make I think that
is an interest of brevity I'll say make
a couple of more remarks and I will pass
out oh you've seen the chart and I will
pass them out back there
um
I think the the point is you know if if
you have Energy Efficiency and there are
savings that money goes back into the
economy and when money is saved in an
economy it gets spent Again by somebody
else and then somebody else gets the
money and so on there's a I think it may
be um
John Maynard Keynes or something like
that theory but basically money that's
poured back in gets spent again and the
next person spends 80 percent and the
next person spends 80 percent so those
savings have an impact on the economy on
well-being across the state even if it
doesn't particularly
it just has that impact over and over
again I don't know how that works
personally but
anyhow
um
that's there's just so many reasons to
go go For Broke on this now I like the
idea of this bill as it is
because it isn't trying to reach for the
sky and so on but you know I'd be the
last person to complain if you um
just ended it all together I would like
to caution that I had such bills to re
to end the Reggie rebate
um I put in three bills during three of
my
uh terms here and um one of the two of
them passed the House and Senate and
they were both vetoed by the governor so
be we want to be a little careful
and I think this bill might make a
some good Headway and I really am happy
to see it thank you very much
I'm willing to answer questions
thank you honorable John Mann for coming
up here today and giving us this little
presentation do we have questions for
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question for me
um I I contract with NH the NH saves
program on the commercial side
and we always we we all know that they
and I was hoping somebody from the
utilities would be here but I'll ask you
um we know that the residential side of
the NH saves program always runs out of
money always and so we always have to
tell people you know if you're going to
plan an Energy Efficiency project in
your house do it earlier rather than
later in the year
if we increased the money from one
dollar to three dollars do you think it
would alleviate that problem
I don't have the numbers and I so I
couldn't answer it but it certainly
seems to me tripling the amount of
funding would be a very good idea
and you could actually do um more I mean
you know this it's the idea of doing the
um the most egregent fixing the worst
problems first and going on to the next
and there's the idea of trying to do the
most you can in each house get done
there's also some education that could
be done and that would be inexpensive
because people can do a lot on their own
but I don't think people realize the
importance for example of having fresh
air directed to anything that burns
anything in the house whether it's your
fireplace or you know gas stove or
anything like that without fresh air
coming in from Outdoors it's going to
come in through leaks all over the house
thank you
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I actually did an
analysis similar to this in a completely
different context many years ago in an
entrepreneurship course
but it assumed that uh this linear
increase as you have here for the linear
increase in the actual Energy Efficiency
effort is truly a linear increase
is that really what we were going to see
or or is it more like the first thing
you do is going to give you a lot of
improvement then the next thing and
maybe a little less and you're going to
get diminishing returns rather than a
linear increase yeah that's a good
question
I don't know I have no way to and in
fact I also think that the um that chart
on the one side is very steep
the the parabola is very Steep and
that's way too steep I I don't think
um in any building that uh you know a
thousand dollars worth of
uh
Energy Efficiency is going to
immediately produce a thousand dollars
worth of reduction in heat or anything
like that I think you probably have a
you know one to four or one to five but
so your break-even point is five times
further out than uh than the sharply
Rising Parabola but um again I think all
representative Reynolds has a question
thank you Mr chairman um nonetheless
could you uh compare or contrast the
usefulness or the re and the return on
investment between money
devoted to Energy Efficiency programs
like this and money
that we spend on the low income heating
energy assistance program in which we
just give low-income folks money to pay
their bills
well this I think there's an economic
Story and there's also you know being
sympathetic with people but I I think
any money you give to somebody for bill
paying assistance is going to go
straight to the oil company and any
money you spend on Energy Efficiency is
um it's going to take longer so there's
a lot of figuring out and so on it's
going to take longer for the impact to
come back but it will stay in the
economy and multiply as I said before
but it will also pay for jobs and Energy
Efficiency for people who aren't you
know all that skilled doesn't take a
whole lot to
pick a shingle off outside of a house
drill a hole
blow insulation into the wall cavity
put the shingle back you know and go
around the house and it's very effective
my wife bought a
before I married her and maybe that's
why I did I don't know but anyway she
bought this Grand Old
house a big house it might have been the
owner of a super I mean in one of these
low low price department stores in
Boston it was the Raymond's family
anyway and it was covered with asbestos
shingle which means that people trying
to control their heat
because it's sort of an insulator anyway
you met State Mass Save came in and in
six hours drilled holes inside the house
throughout the in all floors blue
insulation throughout the house
um
and I checked a few years later and I
went way to the highest point took the
collaborates off and the sheathing off
it was packed solid all the way to the
top that blowing in cellulose really
works anyway
um
I don't know she bought the house for
110 000 we sold it for 550 and Zillow
has it for 1.1 million million because
people with that Energy savings can put
it into renovation
we could take those asbestos shingle off
and have a guide do what they call a
painting restoration scrape and paint
throw away rotten things and replace
them and paint it and the house looked
terrific when we sold it
my wife had to personally
get the raccoons out but other than that
they're in the
Energy Efficiency work kind of
imprisoned uh family raccoon so thank
you any I'll
I love to tell stories I better shut up
before I waste all your time
okay seeing no more questions we thank
you
is there anyone else who has not spoken
on this bill who would like to speak on
it
seeing none we will be in recess until 3
30 when we will
open a public hearing on House Bill 524
relative to the no that's the wrong one
house bill 233 relative to useful
thermal energy under the renewable
portfolio standard
here's sitting over there
okay
um we're gonna
call to order
hb233 and introduce representative Rose
chairman Vose to introduce his bill
thank you Mr Vice chair good afternoon
colleagues I'm here to introduce House
Bill 233 FN which is a bill relative to
useful thermal energy under the
renewable portfolio standard
as those of you who know me well know
one of my motivations in life is to
lower rate payer costs whenever I can
and I've introduced this bill to do just
that
how will this bill lower ratepayer costs
it will lower them by increasing the
number of thermal wrecks that are
available for purchase by utilities
and by increasing that number it will
also lower the number of alternative
compliance payments that the utilities
must make when there is a shortage of
these thermal class 1 thermal wrecks
because alternative compliance payments
are more expensive than Rex
so if there are more wrecks
and fewer acps
rate payer costs will go down
that's the motivation behind this bill
a secondary motivation
is a
somewhat cultural motivation
as any of you who have visited a
historical society in New Hampshire have
noticed if you look at photographs that
were taken back in the early days of
Photography 1840 1850
the one feature you'll notice about
photographs taken in New Hampshire back
then if there are photographs of the
landscape
is an amazing absence of trees
by 1840 in New Hampshire there were very
few trees left
because people cut them all down to
build homes
heat homes and cook food
so there is a a cultural
thread that runs through our existence
here in New Hampshire that burning wood
is a good thing for us to do we've we've
done it for years and years and years
if you look around at New Hampshire
today though
there is tons of wood out there that
we're obviously not burning
and as you've heard people testify
before this committee before
two-thirds of the wood in New Hampshire
is low-grade wood it's really not good
to use to build houses make furniture or
do other useful things with wood but
it's great for burning
you can burn it to make electricity as
the biomass plants do a couple of them
up north
or you can burn it in a wood stove or a
wood boiler
and while it's not the most efficient
way to heat a house
the BTUs and wood are
fewer than the BTUs and some other fuels
nevertheless it does work and
as one of my friends recently reported
to me he's been burning wood in New
Hampshire for most of his life and he
recently converted from a wood stove to
a wood pellet stove and he said he
couldn't believe how much more efficient
a wood pellet stove was then his older
more traditional
so what this bill does is it actually
makes it easier
for and more affordable for people to
install
wood boilers and apply for renewable
the way the log currently
is written
in order to prove that the wood you're
using in your wood boiler is equivalent
to
certain megawatt hours of electricity to
qualify for a wreck you need a meter you
need to be able to meter the BTUs
and then there's a table that you can
use to to calculate
based on how many BTUs you use how many
wrecks you could qualify for
those meters however are kind of
expensive
and the average homeowner probably can't
afford to buy such a meter
so they
are unable basically to apply for class
one thermal Rex as a result
what this bill will do
is remove the requirement for a meter
and ask the department of energy to come
up with an alternative way to calculate
based on the amount of wood that's being
burned but being used typically wood
chips
to come up with a way to to verify what
the the equivalent in megawatt hours
would be so that people could qualify
for class 1 thermal Rex
may or may not accomplish that purpose
the department of energy will testify
once I'm done here
that they have alternative language that
they think might work better
to accomplish the same purpose
and that's fine with me I don't care
what language we end up using I don't
care what part of Statute we end up
modifying as long as we accomplish the
purpose which is to expand
the ability of wood burners to qualify
for class one thermal Rex
because the more of those wrecks that
are out there
the lower cost will be for rate bears
so that's uh
my rationale for doing this bill I'm not
going to go any further because there's
a lot of other people who want to
testify but I'm happy to take questions
uh looks like you didn't get your point
so
but I'll call on uh representative
Winnie Thomas first thank you very much
Mr Vice chair
um on line four it says that um verified
by a method that is satisfactory to the
Department of energy could you define
satisfactory
that is a nebulous term I would agree
but uh one that it basically means that
a method that the department would
accept as verification of the amount of
energy used and its equivalent in
Rec applicable energy follow-up
follow-up thank you by giving the sole
authority to the doe could this method
be in any way abused
I'll let the com the department comment
on that thank you very much
representative Kaplan
thank you Mr Vice chair and thank you uh
Mr chair
for uh presenting this um I just have a
question maybe you can answer it I don't
know because it's not Apparent from the
language of the bill but you did mention
uh you want to increase Rex for people
who are burning wood would that include
any kind of wood stove or is it just
simply in your mind limited to pellet uh
boilers or do you have a specific uh
type of wood burning apparatus that you
have in mind
personally I'd like to see it apply to
any kind of wood burning but there are
people who will testify asked after me
who can answer that question more
precisely people who involve directly
involved in the wood industry and in the
representative Coleman
Corman
you look like a Coleman but that's okay
my apologies do I look like a camping
tent
thank you Mr Vice chair and thank you Mr
chairman for taking my question so I
just want to make sure I understand so I
have a wood stove at home and I burn
about two cords two three chords a year
so in in in your view in your fantasy
world right maybe not fantasy world in
your Ideal World let me put it that way
um I could actually apply for Rex doing
that
you could oh okay absolutely okay thanks
thank you chair thank you for taking out
this question
um and I imagine we will probably be
seeing an amendment on this so I'm going
to try to limit my questions to some
degree
um but and you know I'm a big believer
in Homegrown Solutions and wood is to my
mind a renewable in New Hampshire
um and I understand the barriers uh
posed by trying to meet her
uh wood in order to come up with a
verifiable wreck
um
there are other Industries in New
Hampshire other Renewables will produce
racks as well could you see uh applying
this verification process to any other
uh New Hampshire Renewables that are
eligible for Rex
I can't thank any off the top of my head
but that's a subject for another day
that we could explore certainly I think
I think for this bill we'd want to
confine our effort to getting class one
thermal Rex I I should have been
I have one quick question if this bill
increase the market for the wood
industry
I believe it would because if more
people are able to to get Wrecks for
installing wood pellet stoves and more
people might do just that so it might
stimulate not only the the burner
business but also the the wood
harvesting business because there'd be
more demand for pellets
great seeing no other questions thank
you for Testimony Mr chair and I will
call upon uh Josh Elliott Elliott from
Doe
good afternoon Mr Vice chairman members
of the committee again for the record
Josh Elliott director of the division of
policy and programs with the New
Hampshire Department of energy the
department is neutral on this bill
um as the prime sponsor had mentioned
sort of the goal of this is that we also
see the department is to increase the
number of thermal wrecks or T-rex as
they are called I think that's probably
the most fun acronym we have the
department but
um
that are available for purchase
in our uh last annual report for the
renewable energy fund
um acps and the value of uh just over
2.8 million dollars were made
um just for thermal racks for these
T-Rex for class 1 thermal Rex
um so there's definitely a shortage of
these wrecks that are available
um in the market uh which means that the
electric distribution utilities as well
as competitive suppliers are then
required to make those alternative
compliance payments so um as the prime
sponsor had mentioned we do have a
couple of suggestions about ways that
the bill could be improved I do have
suggestions of language I want to be
careful I know my colleague Mr Roberge
is far more versed in house committee
rule process so I want to be very
careful um please cut me off if I'm
wandering too far astray but essentially
and I'm happy to distribute these as
well
that if we bifurcate the uh the current
statute
leaving the existing stat attitude for
large let me just make sure I'm
referring to the correct
reference here yes if we distinguish
between large thermal sources and small
thermal sources so small thermal sources
are defined in POC rules which will
eventually become doe rules of of 1
million btu or less
so
the goal of that and a lot of these
smaller units as the prime sponsor had
mentioned it's not cost effective for
the owner to put in one of these meters
usually the meter ends up costing just
as much as the installation of the
system so it doesn't really make sense
for on a small scale to actually install
these
so the the suggested language would
bifurcate that leave the existing
Statute in place for the large thermal
sources so your you know your Wood-Fired
power plants your larger things larger
sources that can afford and it makes
sense as part of their calculus and
installing these systems to put those in
but for the you know average residential
homeowner who may have a wood pellet
boiler as their heating Source rather
than spending double the amount just to
get a meter there would be an
alternative measure come up by the
department in order to make them
eligible to generate T-Rex
so with that I I'm happy to pass out
suggested language but I don't again
don't want to run a foul of any
committee procedures you you said you
had something written down for all of us
or just yes yes I have copies you can
you can pass it around we'll keep it for
uh
I'm assuming that that's an amendment or
or just suggestions it is um they are I
just suggested language so it's not in
the official OLS version oh okay okay
fine okay thank you so with that uh Mr
chair Mr Vice chair excuse me I'm happy
to take any questions the committee may
have
representative ones
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um
you know I'm not sure if you're the
right person to ask this or not but I
was struggling a little bit with the
language in paragraph two
um and and and trying to reconcile that
with the language in paragraph one
paragraph one seems seemed to say that
um
you know the department is going to
Define an approach on how to handle
measuring
thermal output and then paragraph two
kind of says but you know if somebody
has a different approach then maybe the
department is willing to accept that
and I don't know if I misread that or if
that to me seemed kind of problematic
it um I would be hopeful that any
methodology that the department would
come up with we would go through
probably we would I shouldn't say
probably we would go through a
stakeholder process to get input from
folks either who are users who gen who
you know either who install these types
of systems to figure out okay what's the
best way to really be measuring them
um but to your point yes you could run
into a situation of where maybe there's
a disagreement half the folks think one
way is the best had another folks other
folks I think the other way is the best
and then we sort of get get stuck in the
middle of trying to sort out which which
methodology should be used and then
we're in theory dealing with a um
a potential onslaught of waiver requests
that have to be reviewed and then either
representative Kaplan
yeah I guess I'll go thank you Mr by
Sarah um I guess I'll ask this question
it might be jumping the gun a little bit
you mentioned rule making in terms of
the methodology but uh I'm just curious
would would in your mind with that
methodology have to include some sort of
uh
prerequisite that whatever residence was
applying would have to be you know
adequately insulated before they could
apply for something like this
um how do you do you mean insulating
like their home has to be insulated oh
so they wouldn't just be you know
burning a whole bunch in order to
generate a whole bunch of wrecks yeah
um I think that probably if I were to
guess
um thank you for the question if I were
to guess I would think that the value of
the
um the the wood that you're putting in
um in order to burn would probably be
more valuable than the racks you would
happen to be generating
um but that's not to say that you could
end up with some right you wouldn't want
to end up with some absurd result of
where you have somebody who's just
essentially burning a whole bunch of
wood and then just minting wrecks that
way
representative Corman
thank you Mr Vice chair and thank you
for taking my question so I'm still just
trying to understand
um a means of verifying the useful
energy output so you know let's say as I
was asking before I I'm at home I'm
burning my two to three chords a year
how could we measure that that output
would it be that I present my bill from
the guy who supplies my wood and what if
I'm supplying my own wood and don't have
a bill I mean how would this work
um thank you for the question I was
actually thinking of that in the back in
terms of of how you do for how you would
adequately measure for somebody who is
essentially self-reporting right they
may have a bunch of Timberland on there
on their property
um and they're using that that one I
think is a bit of a harder question to
answer but certainly something we would
certainly have to consider as part of
this for somebody who gets Uh Wood
delivered so whether it's either in a
pelletized form
um or their you know dimensional wood
chips or something like that there's a
um you know they're generally treated to
an extent of where you can be able to
measure by weight so you'll basically
rather than you know think of like uh if
you're oil or propane you get a certain
gallons you know how many you know how
much you can get out of each gallon the
same idea assuming that the wood chips
and the pellets are treated to certain
conditions
um you know they're at the same uh or
within the same ballpark of sort of
moisture content and things like that
um that you'd be able to come up with
some methodology again that only counts
for deliverable when you get it off you
know get it off the truck there's a
blower it
um into whatever holding container but
to your point yes for somebody who's
doing it themselves they're cutting wood
on their back lot it gets a little
trickier
representative otter
thank you Mr chairman I had to write
this a couple times so I can incorporate
T-Rex another question thank you for
larger systems qualifying for T-Rex
requires meeting certain emission
that is a good question I would have to
check with the rest of the statute
um I know our colleagues at DES
generally regulate error emissions
um and I would need to I would need to
confer with them before I gave you a
firm answer on that
follow-up and you'll get back to us yes
with that thank you yes of course
representative Summers
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh quick question I
have we hear plenty of testimony about
how New Hampshire should be able to
follow the lead or mirror or match what
other states in New England around us
are doing when it comes to Renewables
and if we were where to follow the state
below south of us Massachusetts I
believe is it true that they view
burning wood as not a renewable
um thank you very much for the question
um that is correct they are in the
process I don't know if they're they've
quite finished yet but they're in the
process of removing um what we would
consider class 3 biomass Recs
um as as eligible for uh renewable
generation
representative Winnie Thomas
thank you Mr Vice chair
um
in this process would there be a process
I would thank you for the question
um it's not specified specifically in
the statute I think generally uh
regarding best practices there would
probably be some sort of appeal decision
or if there's some
um uh some sort of um or grounds for an
appeal I think the department if if the
committee decide to move forward with
the bill I think we would
um uh we would not be we would not be
hostile to the idea that an appeal
process would be put in I think it was
General best practice thank you thank
you
okay I think we'll move on thank you so
much
oh yeah I didn't you didn't have your
thank you Vice chair
um and thanks for the uh taking my
question
um not speaking about the uh how to
incorporate this but about the rec
Market
um of course whenever you mess with any
what have you come involved in any
Market there's potential things don't
work the way you want
um have you considered the possibility
of putting more wrecks into the market
May depress the existing Rec Market
rather than making more available
thank you for the question
um as you mentioned right it's a it's a
dynamic Market
um the market uh dictates what the price
what the trading price of those wrecks
are and where they settle depending on
the policies of both New Hampshire as
well as other states
um given the track record that we have
seen
um with alternative compliance payments
made by Electric distribution utilities
as well as a competitive supplier uh we
have seen that
more
alternative compliance payments are
being made disproportionately for
thermal racks which indicates either
that they aren't available or if they
are available they are
settling in other states where the
alternative compliance payment is lower
so it makes more sense from a financial
basis that the company say if saves a
large company decides okay we're going
to settle these in another jurisdiction
I'm making up States let's just say
Massachusetts
um you know they may have to pay an ACP
of 80 again making up numbers versus New
Hampshire it would be 65 and change
that it makes more financial sense for
them to settle them somewhere else and
just make the payments here for a number
of the smaller competitive suppliers
sometimes they just don't have the
volume that it doesn't make sense for
them to go out to actually procure the
racks themselves so they'll make
alternative compliance payments but if
you look at our annual report it's
pretty much across the board okay
got it right here in front of me
um yeah all with the exception of
Liberty all the major utilities
um
so that's the the co-op eversourcing
Unitil all made class one thermal acps
as well as pretty much most of the
competitive suppliers there's a couple
here that didn't but I suspect that they
probably
um
uh either we're able to
from a national basis they were able to
sort of Cobble them together
thank you for that excellent answer
you're very welcome thank you uh we'll
move on thank you so much for your
testimony always a pleasure to have you
Michelle yet thank you very much Mr Vice
chair I know I'm pale invitation to Mr
Roberts but I try my best
I'm going to call on Mr Michael Licata
foreign
Michael Licata representing eversource
also a pale imitation of Mr Roberge
um
happy to testify this afternoon in
support of HB
233 as you've heard from previous
testifiers
the bill aims to address a metering
issue that we believe has really held
back a number of thermal sources from
being able to participate in the class
one thermal carve out of the RPS
generating more wrecks as the bill
sponsor said will reduce the utilities
need to make alternative compliance
payments alternative compliance payments
just by way of background are
essentially the ceiling or the cap so
that's the highest amount that the
utility can pay so a wreck by its very
nature if its purchase will be purchased
less than that ceiling thereby reducing
costs and as Mr Elliott testified to
uh all the utilities as well as I should
say most of the utilities as well as the
competitive suppliers uh did make
significant ACP payments uh because of
the lack of availability of wrecks
eversource in the last compliance period
2021 uh made payments uh of 1.2 million
dollars just for our thermal wreck
obligation for ACP so certainly anything
we can do to increase that Supply not
only reduces the cost of electricity but
also provides a benefit to the
individuals producing those wrecks so
the financial incentive with that I'd be
happy to answer any questions that the
committee may have
representative Bernardi
thank you Mr Vice chair
um so you heard the doe propose
potentially a large and small uh wreck
concept here uh generator I do believe
there are any
um wood burning entities that are on the
large-scale side that would benefit from
a fix to the metering issue or are they
all well captured with the current
metering standard
yeah I'll defer that to folks from the
wood industry who can speak much better
to the how they would comply with the
metering issue I would say
um I think this is in response to some
questions that were asked the class one
thermal is not wood alone it's solar
thermal as well as geothermal and and
biomass but there are I think someone
had asked this question there are
emissions requirements associated with
the biomass which as the chair had said
the bill sponsor uh really I believe and
obviously others in the industry can
speak to this as well confines it to
pellets wood pellets in order to meet
those emission standards so very long
way of of saying I think there are
others behind me who could answer that
question more much better than I could
thank you
representative munz
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question do you have any idea
how many additional wrecks this metering
would or this this would generate I I
don't again folks within the industry
who work with the individuals who are
installing these these pellet boilers
would have a much better better idea of
that again for the utility
excuse me from the utility standpoint
you know we just see what's available uh
that complies with the RPS that's been
certified
to generate the wreck we don't really
have insight into what the the industry
is doing on the other end of that
thank you
so you know other questions thank you Mr
locata oh sorry
for episode Wendy Thomas thank you um I
just have a a general question
um our environmental impact is that
considered when um you give out wrecks
like this or is I I mean sure I don't
know I mean that's sure
um so the types of technologies that
qualify for the state RPS are specified
in State Statute most of them don't have
emissions profiles so whether it's Hydro
or solar or wind when it comes to
biomass which does have an emissions
profile there's actually a rather
elaborate
um
I think the Des might have last left but
elaborate emission standard that they
have to comply with in order to qualify
for generating wrecks it's a different
standard for for thermal wrecks
um but there is a standard so
essentially the state of New Hampshire
has made a public policy decision of the
emissions profile the environmental
profile of the technology that can
generate a wreck in New Hampshire okay
thank you very much
and with that thank you Mr Lakota thanks
for your testimony right now I'm going
to ask a question to Mr Sam Evans Brown
what uh
there's been reference to wanting to
hear people from the wood industry would
you care if uh is is he part of your
testimony because I only have one card
for
who represent
okay I I'll bring some wood people up
first and then you can go go next time
so um I'm not sure which order this is
and I've been kind of waiting to see Mr
Nichols come up here because you come
I used to live up on Dame Hill very
close
thank you Mr Vice chairman and members
of the committee my name is Scott
Nichols I run a company called tarm
biomass
we import and distribute uh wood wood
pellet and wood chip boilers around the
country
and I've been in this industry a long
time I've seen many of you in this room
or a room like it before
I am also a individual seller of T-Rex
in a building that I own that I run my
business from so I kind of come at this
from many different uh levels
uh I am here to support
um the bill is introduced
um for going back about 10 years ago
working with then the puc
this was a big question how do we how do
we get residential uh pellet boilers at
that time
um to be part of the t-rec program and
the the cost of metering
those spoilers made it uh difficult
prohibitive and that's why I think
um we've settled at this point to just
having T-Rex for uh uh commercial
boilers um this the smaller boilers just
don't produce enough T-Rex to justify
the cost of metering and verifying the
output of the meter uh so this I feel uh
by loosening this standard for the
smaller boilers uh perhaps allowing uh
T-Rex to be created on the basis of
metered wood uh in the case of wood
pellets uh through certified scales of
the trucks that deliver the wood perhaps
receipts from the stores where tons of
pellets are purchased I think there's a
way to verify that pellets are being
consumed perhaps with a some sort of
minimum efficiency and some sort of
minimum emissions criteria I think it's
totally possible and we've discussed
this for many years in the industry
again with the puc
um
uh someone asked
how many T-Rexes would create
and I think that's a great question but
it's it's it's a difficult one because
there are so many other factors that
influence how many new
pellet burning wood chip burning wood
burning equipment uh or appliances enter
the market each year and one of the
biggest factors is the cost of oil or
gas the Alternatives and more and more
of the cost of power I think a lot of
people have put heat pumps in with a
promise that it's going to be very
inexpensive and for sure it's less
expensive than oil and gas but now we've
seen power prices increase in quite a
bit
so what we're we're basically in a
period of energy turmoil I think and I
think it's going to be this way for a
while because it's confusing for bankers
and investors to know what to put their
money into
they're nervous about investing in in
future oil uh and gas exploration and
development they're nervous about
Refinery growth and so we're going to
we're we're basically through policy to
increase the amount of Renewables
available to everyone we're in a period
of turmoil and one thing that's not in
turmoil in New Hampshire is wood supply
our industry can help
we're not going to help everybody but we
can take a significant amount of stress
off of heating bills and the
availability of heating fuels and if we
can encourage people
to buy what I sell and other products
like them I I think we can we can help
out the state by keeping more fuel
dollars here we can help out the utility
and and we can just take a load off the
grid all in all
personally speaking I I use about 35
tons of wood pellets a year
T-Rex pay me back uh somewhere between
2500 and 3 000 for the purchase of those
pellets so it's a significant uh
encouragement inducement to to continue
to burn wood pellets so if we want to
burn wood in this state if we believe in
our our own uh renewable resource I
and I'll conclude with that if you take
any questions thank you very much
representative partial
thank you Vice chair take up my question
and thank you for uh being here today
um I could give you an idea of these
meters uh now you're in a commercial
operation obviously
that's how I sell mine yes but if I
talking about a residential operation in
order to sell Rex I need to purchase a
meter in order to uh
see the BTUs that I'm producing
could you give me a rough Ballpark and I
sure won't hold you to it but a rough
ballpark of what the cost of one of
those meters would be costs about five
thousand dollars to purchase and install
a meter that's why you don't see them at
residential installations thank you
we're
so obviously I I used to be on resources
and so a lot of my questions are
environmental if we open this up
um to
everybody getting thermoorex are we
going to I mean um the the sponsor of
the bills said that you know in the
olden days you didn't see many trees
because we burned them all are we going
to go back to that
I seriously doubt that we could ever go
back to that
nobody goes into the woods to cut trees
for fuel there's no value in those trees
for fuel if they're worth basically
nothing
and so you can't you can't charge enough
to harvest them so the wood that that
we're burning for fuel is residual to
the main Harvest which is for lumber
and the problem that we have is not that
we're cutting too many trees the problem
that we're beginning to see is that
forests are under pressure to be
hydrated which means that people go in
and take out the good trees
the nice straight tall ones and they're
leaving all the junk
um that basically is crowded and and
worthless and diseased
and
um with climate change and with
increasing number of pests thinking
about the emerald ash borer we actually
are under some pressure to have more
means for getting rid of this wood and
making our forests more resilient and
healthy so I believe that by creating
stronger consistent markets for wood I
think we do a benefit to our forests
thank you Mr chair and I'm your neighbor
right down the road I'm from Lebanon
um so I'm just wondering is there some
sort of resale market for pellets I'm
just thinking imagine I buy a lot of
pellets
get the Rex and then sell them a little
bit you know to my neighbors but I keep
the wrecks and and then they can't I
mean is that a scenario that could
happen
I suppose it could happen but it seems
sort of
uh economically silly uh maybe I'm not
seeing the whole picture but if
anybody's buying pellets
uh they're they're they're paying some
rate right and so I'm not sure what
benefit there is for them to keep the
wrecks
and and
sell them in in the neighbor down the
street doesn't get the rexes somehow it
the economics don't work out
um I I some pellets are sold for animal
betting
um but that I think that's really rare
um they're expensive
um so I don't see that being an issue I
think we need some kind of verification
and maybe it's
you know you get your fuel your fuel uh
your your your weight ticket from the
delivery or your receipt from Home Depot
or wherever the pellets are purchased
and then maybe there's a maybe there's a
side verification like the number of
operating hours each year for the
machine that somehow
proves that or at least comes close to
proving that that number of pellets was
consumed I think it's possible to come
up with something to verify
I have one last question uh it was
mentioned uh we've been told before that
there's not that much you know high
grade Lumber here in New Hampshire so uh
when you say that you use wood from
residual
um
operations that cut down
wood for lumber uh I'm I'm curious what
what type of
how much of it do we have here and what
kind of a market do we have uh because
the two statements didn't seem to quite
correlate so if you could kind of give
us a picture on where we get that wood
from
I will explain it to you in the simplest
terms that I have and I've learned it
from my friend and colleague behind me
Charlie nibling
75 percent of our forests are low-grade
wood 25 are high grade approximately
but 75 percent of the value is in that
25 percent of high grade
and the 25 or maybe even lower now is in
in the low grade wood so it's not that
we don't have high grade wood it's just
that when a harvest is made
the there is a huge volume
that is that is not very valuable and a
small volume that is but in order to
have a healthy Forest after a logging
cut is done
that low-grade wood has to be taken too
or else all that's left is the low grade
so
um part of good stewardship is is taking
some of all of it and leaving some and
providing proper spacing and species
that are going to flourish
that's an excellent explanation
um so thank you for that excuse me
see no other questions thank you so much
thank you I appreciate you coming here
I'm going to call on a Morton Bailey
from lime green Heat
from lime
yeah another stomping ground of mine
thank you all for having me here um so
uh lime green Heats a uh what I call a
wood pellet fuel company so we do uh
Sales and Service of fully automated
wood pellet boilers and furnaces and we
deliver bulk wood pellets
um so our fuel delivery companies just
like an oil or propane company so we
drive a tank truck to somebody's home a
hook a hose up to a storage bin that's
in their basement or a silo outside at a
business or municipality and we blow
those wood pellets in just like an oil
delivery is pumped into your tank
um so our boilers that we work with are
a little more sophisticated
um meeting uh the the EPA standards for
efficiency and our products that are
rebated through the department of
Energy's sustainable energy rebate
programs
um so from our perspective in support of
this bill we can see the ability to show
a metered amount of fuel that goes to
each one of the these systems annually
along with that we do service of these
systems so as Scott mentioned we can
track that the service hours the
operational hours of the burner so that
gives us that that two-stage system of
verifying the fuel that's burned through
the operational hours of the appliance
the other benefit we have is servicing
that Appliance annually just like you
have your gas or oil boiler service so
again we can help to kind of verify the
efficiency in the operational status of
that piece of equipment so we look at
this you know our industry the thing
that kind of turns us on about it is
getting truly hyper local energy so we
know that our wood is coming you know
from within the state or communities
State communities around it and are
going directly to offset Oil and Propane
consumption here in the state and
building jobs and putting money back
into the into the economy through that
um so we just see a lot of benefits for
the state having this really a an energy
creation from our Forest Products
um so the the ability to have these
thermal wrecks enter in the market it's
just going to help incentivize
homeowners
um small building owners to start to
make that move to New Hampshire made or
Vermont made or man-made fuel here
um so it's really keeping that Regional
energy
um here in the state
um and I think we've you know there are
totally some reasonable questions here
on how that's all going to be done
across the board when it comes to
different wood heating appliances
um I think one thing to keep it in mind
as well
is that there's already some some
statutes built in so you know older
appliances wouldn't qualify
um so even if you were a large school
right now if you'd put in a woodchuck
boiler uh X number of years ago you
wouldn't qualify to sell thermal Rex so
I think that can kind of help to clean
up a little bit of that going backwards
on older systems too
um and I think
this is going to go back to help build
that reserve of money to go towards
these rebate programs that the the
department of energy runs now so by
having more wrecks go out into the
market it in turn is going to feed back
in to these rebate programs
um you know which is converting you know
residential and Commercial systems over
to wood pellets and wood chips here in
the state
um so yeah glad to answer any questions
representative's daughter
thank you I'm just curious how many wood
pellets could you fit in this room in
this room that's a great question
um so you would probably fit uh
somewhere in the area of 30 tons in this
space
sure representative Bernardi sorry I
could do the cubic footage and figure it
out for you do you have a weight
question
a weight question
thank you Mr Vice chair
um so you said uh you don't believe that
uh older uh units that may have been put
in schools before or whatever would
qualify why do you say that why do you
make that I think Charlie can can answer
that but I believe there's a a date
um you know prior to X year those
systems weren't able to qualify for
thermal Rex
um it's not an environmental standard no
exactly I think it was a standard that
the the puc built into that thank you
representative partial
thank you chair
um you I'm this might have been a better
question for the sponsor but knowing
that Massachusetts is not a lumber
intensive State however Maine and
Vermont are are you aware of programs
like this in order to get down to this
level are they possible in those States
actually in Massachusetts
um I I believe I think Maine is coming
up with a program but Massachusetts has
a program called aches another great
acronym here which allows homeowners to
sell thermal renewable energy credits in
their state based off from delivered
thank you so much
representative buns thank you very much
thank you for coming in
um I'll ask I'll ask you the question I
asked earlier do you have any idea how
many additional wrecks this could
generate in New Hampshire I I don't I
have not uh I've not done that math okay
okay you see no other questions thank
you so much very interesting thank you
for coming
and now we will get to Mr Charlie
nibling who I'm sure will shed light on
thank you Mr Vice chairman
uh thank you representative Vos and and
other co-sponsors of of this legislation
and I'm I'm here
as a long time advocate uh and supporter
of the use the intelligent use of wood
to make energy in the state of New
Hampshire
with a particular focus on thermal
energy over the course of my career
speaking in support of House Bill 233 I
did submit testimony through the online
portal uh that addresses a number of
questions that have come up so uh when
you get a chance you can give it a read
I did bring a few copies but I'm trying
to get away from
endowing you all with too much paper and
keep it all digital uh
this is in my mind a very simple Bill
the the words shall be metered which
have been in the statute since
2012 have made it
impossible for the Public Utilities
Commission and now the department of
energy to consider
uh verification and accountability
protocols for thermal Rex
that do not require a meter
and all this bill does is give them the
authority to consider alternative
methodologies it doesn't mandate that
people will either petition or perhaps
they'll
consider a stakeholder meeting and throw
ideas around and ultimately and my
experience with the puc over the years
and with the Department of energy is
that they interpret their stature
statutory Authority very strictly
um and very conservatively and I don't
think they're going to do anything or
approve anything that is contrary to the
intent of this legislation
I just want to read
um
uh one quick item here from my from my
testimony
um and that is that petitioners are
still going to have to demonstrate that
an alternative to BQ meters can ensure
accurate and independently verifiable
data
as the basis for for uh generating and
ultimately qualifying thermal racks
that's the standard that the department
of energy will have to meet in whatever
alternative
methods it it considers
and I did want to address a couple
questions that came up and just correct
the record in in some cases
representative Summers you asked several
weeks ago on House Bill 166 whether
Massachusetts had made the decision to
consider biomass as no longer renewable
that's true for the renewable portfolio
standard which is an electric energy
standard it is not true for the
alternative
portfolio standard which recognizes
renewable thermal energy from biomass
um
quite enthusiastically in fact it's that
statute that this provision
would enable the department of energy to
mimic in terms of some of the
flexibility around
verifying heat energy the state of Maine
has also adopted procedures that allow
fuel input
to serve as a proxy for heat output so
you've got two neighboring states that
have done what this legislation will
authorize the department of energy to
consider
and
with that I would be happy to answer any
questions
excellent
thank you Mr Vice chair
um
this legislation sounds like a good idea
and if it's
meant to lower the price of compliance
by increasing the flow of thermal wrecks
into the market
that sounds like a good idea too since
it sounds like acp's alternative
compliance payments have been the
the norm or uh but are you as a long
time proponent of of the use of
thermal energy and the creation of these
their one result might be a bottoming
out of the price of thermal wrecks and
and should we also consider an
adjustment to the numbers in the thermal
portfolio standard
thank you for the question
representative Reynolds um
I suppose yes I'm I'm concerned I I
think when thermal was added to the RPS
through Senate Bill 218 in 2012. it was
a very small increment as a sort of a
test
uh not long after the thermal Provisions
became
effective in 2014 upon the adoption of
rules
the price of oil and propane
dropped quite dramatically and as Mr
Nichols testified earlier the cost of
conventional fossil heating fuels drives
a lot of the interest in alternatives
when they're cheap as they have been at
various times in the past
people go with convenience they go with
Oil propane and natural gas when they're
expensive people
take a hard look at the Alternatives
heat pumps geothermal solar thermal
solar PV with heat pumps
modern wood heating they start looking
at the alternatives
um
I I think it's appropriate that the
legislature consider adjusting all of
the classes in the RPS as legislation
has contemplated on several occasions
uh
the uh the
RPS effectively comes to an end in 2025
although
it continues at the levels that are in
place the mandates that are in place as
of 220 2025
but it would not be inappropriate for
this body to take a look
at those uh targets uh every other New
England state has
significantly increase their renewable
energy mandates through their RPS or
equivalent programs in recent years
most notably uh Rhode Island which last
year increased their RPS Mandy to 100
percent by 2030. Maine uh Massachusetts
Connecticut 48 percent uh just as a
result of legislation just a couple
years ago whether you agree that that's
the right way to achieve a more
aggressive vision for renewable energy
or not is is a matter for healthy debate
but I think it's appropriate to consider
uh whether or not we're we're at a point
where we need to take another look at
that
thank you
seeing no other questions thank you for
your testimony
and I'll call up
does anyone have any questions for Mr
representative louder Step Up
hi sorry put you on the stand that's
fine
um would you be in favor of having a
single class in the RPS
uh a single just so all renewable energy
and eliminate all the other other
classes
um is that what this bill would do I
mean I I guess I'm a little confused as
to why that question is being posed to
me right now in this particular hearing
you need to follow up yeah well it's
something that we we've talked about
before
um removing classes adding classes so
um just wondered how what you thought
about once just one class yeah well so
so uh I I answer questions like this as
a student of History I think it's it's
worth asking why the RPS is structured
the way it is and the the smaller
subclasses you know uh two three and
four were three and four in particular
were put in place to make sure that
existing sources of generation that
already are in place and functioning in
New Hampshire weren't
um weren't crowded out of the market as
new generation came in and so the the
question that this committee would have
to ask itself is is that legislative
goal no longer a policy priority for the
State of New Hampshire
um when I when I look at the the members
of clean energy New Hampshire many of
which are businesses that are that are
um that are owners of that generation I
think a lot of them would would to have
would take issue with the idea of
eliminating the crap the class structure
because it the class structure
recognizes that there are different
Capital profiles for different types of
businesses that have been in place for
longer you know I think of the hydro
facilities imagine yourself as the owner
of a 100 plus year old piece of
infrastructure that requires constant
maintenance but is having to having to
make a go of it on today's today's
energy markets in which there's lots of
new technologies coming in and so so I
think the class structure really is
something that's that's trying to
preserve fuel diversity and preserve
existing sources of generation now if
the question is it might we change the
RPS to try to try to achieve some other
legislative policy goal I think you know
we'd welcome that type of conversation
but
um you know I I think if if keeping if
the question is do would I keep the RPS
at the at the level that it's at today
so 25 percent renewable energy and then
just eliminate the class structure I
think the risk there is that some of
those existing facilities in New
Hampshire might might get found
themselves crowded out of the market
I I will say I'm surprised that to get
that question now though about biomass
today well to add context we actually
did have a bill come through here that
would have uh had only one one class in
the program so perhaps you missed that
day yes and probably would have had some
good testimony on that uh had you been
here
I'm going to call on representative
partial
and Sheriff
and uh this might be a question that
might be difficult to answer
um but we are speaking of a renewable
product with uh thermal uh with wood
um but it is not carbon neutral
and I guess what I would like to know is
so much I have some Assurance on is that
that will be part of the formula as well
as we go forward and looking how we can
possibly replace our fossil fuel with
wood how does the uh how will that be
affecting our carbon foot fit moving
forward
uh the the the question of the carbon
neutrality of biomass is an incredibly
complicated one that it's actually very
difficult to answer and so uh asserting
that biomass is not carbon neutral I
think actually think is not correct in
fact there are many organizations that
find that do that do assert that that
biomass is carbon neutral of course the
question of how you account for the
carbon emissions in the biospheres as I
said very very complicated I would
answer that the question of carbon
neutrality in New Hampshire's forests
though very simply which is that if you
look at the broad macro Trends which
again I'll do what Scott Nichols did and
say I know this because Charlie nibling
told me
um which is that there that we are
growing vastly more wood than we are
cutting in New Hampshire at current
trends because uh large users of
low-grade wood have have phased phased
out in recent decades so the pulp Mills
uh and now the biomass electric burning
plants up in up in Northern New
Hampshire and so uh we're a long way in
New Hampshire's woods from finding
ourselves in a place where we're where
we're cutting more than we're then we're
burning
um if we were to see those Trends start
to reverse then we might need to get
serious about how are we doing our
carbon Accounting in our woods but as it
stands uh the the the the wood markets
are hurting and that means that there's
a lot of wood growing out there thank
you for your reassurance thank you I'm
gonna end whoops okay I'm gonna ask
clients representative Pelosi he hasn't
uh asked a question yet so
here we are my guest uh thank you Vice
chair
I I wonder if you could ask a question
maybe it's a
you could point the committee to someone
I understand over the years I think it's
eight years
our carbon heat sink in New Hampshire
which I thought was mostly forests has
been
getting smaller
I have the numbers but not in front of
me
but there is data showing our carbon
sink in New Hampshire is lessening and
then I hear more trees are growing do
you know where this carbon normally goes
if it's not going to trees thank you so
I would love to see whatever Source
you're citing uh and and help interpret
it
um my understanding is that the loss of
forest land in New England as a whole
and New Hampshire New Hampshire as well
as part of that you know as part of that
Regional trend is largely driven by
development
um and and as opposed to as opposed to
you know the timber industry uh losing
wood lots and turning them into housing
developments is is the the greatest
threat to the carbon sink in in New
Hampshire
but would love to see that report
whatever it is
you follow up
um Vice chair just to answer the
question it was a I think it's a Federal
Environmental study but I can get that
for you
all right for a few
okay uh represent months I'll take one
last question thank you thank you for uh
being here again today the reason I keep
asking people how many wrecks this could
be could potentially generate is I'm
trying to get a sense of you know what
this what these additional wrecks and
the reduction in ACP payments might have
on power rates
is there any that's that you provide any
insight it's a great question and I
think I could work with the folks who
are have a better uh a better finger on
the pulse of the pellet industry in
particular to try to come up with some
sort of estimate I think generally
speaking any estimate that we were to
come up up with might be a little bit
back of the napkin and so I wouldn't put
a great deal of faith in it
um but you know if you look at the
latest renewable energy fund uh uh
report I mean it's the alternative
compliance payments for for the t-rec
classes in the neighborhood of 1.8
million I think
um and so any any T-Rex that are
generated are going to lower that number
and that's that's the goal of this bill
follower okay so I yeah what I'm trying
to do is just get an order of magnitude
and I think you've kind of provided a
little bit of insight that I mean if all
of the 1.8 million went away which it
wouldn't on year one you're not correct
you're not talking about a dramatic
change in in electric rates okay thank
you
okay thank you for your testimony
okay
Jason stock
how could you possibly have not come
you know I thought I was gonna
sneak out of the room and wouldn't be
any questions uh for the record I'm
Jason stock I'm the executive director
of New Hampshire Timberland Owners
Association and
although I hadn't planned and we I come
in support of the bill
we do support the bill we have members
that um participate in the t-rec market
they burn wood
um and so we we do come in support of
the bill I just wanted to kind of
clarify a couple things
um and I'd be happy to answer questions
is is a state we do continue to grow
more wood than we Harvest
um where is carbon stored it is stored
in the leaves the branches and even in
the soil so there's a there's carbon
even in the soil in in a forest soil
both you know in the Duff and of course
in the roots of the of the plants
themselves
so when you look at Carbon and there's
there are studies upon studies that look
at this
um there are studies that show that even
you know with our forest and they're
continuing to grow
carbon is being continues to be stored
at all levels of of the landscape and so
inasmuch as this bill or even you know
the the biomass energy energy plants if
a couple of those were to come back
online we'll continue I am very
confident that we'll continue to grow
more wood when we look at wood Harvest
and mortality data
and growth data even from back in the
days when Berlin was up and running and
representative Noel knows that facility
used a lot of wood
um even in those days we continue to
have a positive balance of growth in the
state
in fact one of the one of the concerns
when you talk to kind of
silviculturalists and biometricians that
study this one of the concerns is that
our forests are actually getting older
and getting too old and like humans as a
forest gets older its growth starts to
slow
and so when you talk to some of these
folks and even the wildlife people
they'll tell you we don't have enough
younger Forest
we need to be having more forests out
there that are younger so I raised these
points just to show and try to hope to
allay any concerns that this bill or any
of the other biomass bills that you've
heard in in recent weeks that
you know if if adopted we're going to
wake up one morning and there'll be a
moonscape out there with with no trees
and just a field of stumps that's not
going to happen as Scott Nichols had
said
you biomass whether it's wood chips or
wood chips that go into pellets they are
a byproduct of
harvesting for for timber for lumber
um and so with you know two-thirds to
three quarters of everything that's
standing out there but it being low
greed it's just inevitable you're going
to produce it and so this
thermal markets do present an
opportunity it's it's a it do they do
present an opportunity to utilize this
material and so it from the forest but
also from our Mills that are producing
Lumber they take a round log they Square
it up they chip the slabs a lot of that
product goes into these types of
facilities as well so I just wanted to
speak to this and and I think when I
testified on 166 earlier this uh I think
it was two weeks ago I provided a
graphic from our friends at the
Department of Agriculture that shows and
differentiates the carbon Cycles
looking at a geologic versus I think
it's
the biological I'll call it the
biological carbon Cycles
and kind of that difference and I think
that's something we you know this
program does not tap into that geologic
cycle this is on the left side of the
paper with the kind of biologic cycle
so with that I'll be happy to answer any
questions
representative Reynolds Reynolds please
ask your question
thank you Mr Vice chair
um Scott with your testimony today are
you going on record in favor of
discrimination against older forests
I love all forests
and with that we will thank you thank
you Mr Jason stock for answering those
questions and seeing no other speakers
we will close
HB
233 FN
thank you all and I will turn the
meeting over to our wheelchair chair
thanks everybody not much to add but
just to remind you all that Thursday we
will hear two more bills and then we
will have an extensive executive session
starting at one o'clock in the afternoon
representative closure will give us some
statistics about the blue sheet for the
last couple of bills
uh thank you chair and the previous
bill
House Bill 524 the blue sheet was six in
support one opposed on line 47 in
House Bill 233
the blue sheet
had three in support none of polls on
line 50 in support none of pulse thank
you chair okay I apologize
for online 50 and support one a pulse
thank you oh okay
all right
so we're done thanks everybody for being
here today and we look forward to seeing
you on Thursday and of course we'll see
you all tomorrow
in the uh in Representatives Halls house